Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Glaube, jetzt haben wir alle Zahlen durch. Und euch allen dürfte klar sein, wo wir sind. An einem letzten Donnerstag im Monat, nämlich im Chaos Radio, wo Leute von diesem seltsamen Chaos Computer Club, von dem man immer hört, hier in die Sendung kommen, um uns über Dinge zu unterrichten, die dort draußen in dem seltsamen Internet, in dieser großen, weiten Welt so vor sich gehen und die auch noch Leute mitbringen, was auch zum Beispiel heute der Fall ist. Ich begrüße schon mal Jan Schallerböck, hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und den Wetterfrosch, den ihr vielleicht schon kennt, der war schon mal hier. Und es geht heute um Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke. Und die kurze Erklärung ist, ihr kennt alle Facebook und Facebook ist an einem Ort, das führt zu seltsamen Dingen. Wenn so ein großes Netzwerk an einem Ort ist, das hat man ganz gut gesehen in den letzten Wochen am PlayStation Network, ist auch an einem Ort. Und wenn man dann da hingeht, dann Unsinn macht, wird das einfach mal ausgeschaltet. Das will man nicht, da kann auch mehr Unsinn passieren. Deswegen ist die Idee eines dezentralen Netzwerks, dass das ganz kurz erklärt, so was Ähnliches wie Filesharing. Also viele Leute machen irgendwie mit und es verteilt sich alles. Und was es genau bedeutet, das klären wir heute hier in den zwei Stunden Chaos Radio. Wetterfrosch kennt ihr schon. Wetterfrosch ist vom Chaos Computer Club, beschäftigt sich da so mit Dingen, beziehungsweise nochmal genauer eingrenzen für Leute, die dich vielleicht noch nicht kennen.
Ich bin eher im politischen Flügel, aktiv basteln natürlich auch manchmal was. Und bin jetzt nicht so der große Programmierer-Administrator, sondern eigentlich eher auch bei Netzpolitik zum Beispiel, netzpolitik.org, dem Blog aktiv und beschäftige mich auch sehr mit den Aspekten Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit. Und heute geht es ja hier um eine Frage sozusagen, wie das Netz beschaffen sein soll, wie unsere Infrastrukturen funktionieren sollen. Und ich finde das gerade sehr spannend, seitdem dieses Facebook so aufkam, ist das wirklich eine Art und Weise, wie das funktioniert, wie das funktionieren soll. Und das Netzwerk hat irgendwie 600 Millionen Nutzer.
Ganz schön viele auf jeden Fall.
Das drittgrößte Land nach China und Russland, könnte man sagen.
Aber habe ich doch gelesen, es ist so eine Art Sandkasten im Internet. Also da sind die Leute, die sonst noch nicht klarkommen. Die spielen da halt ein bisschen. Also das ist eine Sichtweise darauf.
Du meinst jetzt den Nutzer, nicht die Macher?
Genau, die Nutzer. Jan, bevor du uns jetzt ausführlich erklärst, was das mit den Dezentralen Sozialen Netzwerken zu tun hat, wer bist du, was machst du hier und wie hat man dich hierher geschleift?
Ja, ich bin eigentlich Mitarbeiter vom ULD. Das ist der Datenschutzbeauftragte in Schleswig-Holstein. Und da arbeite ich seit Jahren an der Beforschung von Datenschutztechnologien und begleite eine Reihe von Projekten aus juristischer Sicht mit versucht, das in einer Kombination von Technik und Recht mir anzugucken. Ja, und das Thema Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke ist da vor Jahren schon aufgepoppt. Seit ein paar Jahren hat es die Politik auf dem Schirm, dass es Datenschutzbedenken und Probleme gibt.
Da muss ich direkt noch mal nachfragen, die Politik hat das auf dem Schirm?
Im Prinzip schon, ja.
Da gibt es ja viele normale Nerds, die das vielleicht schon mal gehört haben, und auch gar nicht genau wissen, worum es geht. Aber die Politik hat das jetzt schon auf dem Schirm?
Ich glaube nicht in der Form, über die wir jetzt reden, im Sinne der Dezentralisierung oder Förderierung, das ist zu technisch für die oft. Aber die Politik sieht schon, dass es Probleme gibt im Datenschutz bei sozialen Netzwerken, auf jeden Fall, würde ich schon sagen. Sie wissen überhaupt nicht, wie sie es lösen sollen.
Ah, und da kommen wir ins Spiel. Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, einen Beitrag wollen wir leisten. Das ist der Gedanke, ob wir das komplett im Griff haben, das müssen die Nutzer letztlich entscheiden. Aber die Politik kann da helfen. Aber umgekehrt versuchen wir natürlich mit Technik auch Probleme anzugehen und anzuschauen.
Für die Nutzer gilt heute Abend natürlich wie immer in einem Blumen und auch in einem Chaosradio.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Für uns ist es natürlich auch interessant zu wissen, ob ihr überhaupt so ein dezentrales Netzwerk haben wollt oder ob ihr vielleicht in einem zentralen Netzwerk schon mal was erlebt habt, was euch den Wunsch geweckt hat. Es könnte doch vielleicht noch irgendwie anders gehen. Welche Erfahrung habt ihr da schon gemacht? Was war so schlimm, dass ihr denkt, okay, ich muss jetzt aufhören? Also gibt es bei euch vielleicht tatsächlich Facebook Aussteiger? Weil ich kenne das nur aus Geschichten. Leute sagen, ich mache bei Facebook nicht mehr mit. Also ich kenne nur die zwei Leute. Leute, die sowieso nicht da sind und Leute, die immer da sind. Aber diese wirklichen Aussteiger, die kenne ich eigentlich nicht. Falls ihr dazu gehört, könnt ihr gerne anrufen und könnt uns dann auch erzählen, wie eine Alternative aussehen müsste, die ihr benutzt. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, jetzt mal ganz von vorne angefangen. Ein dezentrales soziales Netzwerk. Wie soll denn das funktionieren? Es ist doch eigentlich so, wenn ich ein soziales Netzwerk habe, dann will ich das an einem Ort haben, da gehen alle hin, befreunden sich miteinander. Und dann hat man so ein Netzwerk. Wie soll denn das dezentral funktionieren?
Man kann sich das zum Beispiel so vorstellen wie E-Mail. E-Mail ist auch ein System, was jetzt nicht von einer Firma in der Hand ist oder von einer großen Organisation oder der deutschen Post, sondern jeder kann einen E-Mailserver aufsetzen. Man kann sich aussuchen zwischen bestimmten Anbietern, die das für einen tun und mit Werbung Geld verdienen, wie gmx, web.de, die meisten Provider, bei denen man sein Internet bezieht, bieten einen auch eine E-Mail-Adresse an. Und es können aber auch Firmen, die sozusagen sagen, unsere Mails sind uns irgendwie wichtig, das möchten wir lieber in unseren Händen halten und das nicht jemand anders anvertrauen, selbst einen E-Mailserver betreiben. Und das machen ja auch viele größere, die meisten größeren Firmen. Und Organisationen, Vereine häufig auch. Und das sind halt eben Datenlager unter ihrer eigenen Hoheit und trotzdem kommen die E-Mails, obwohl es so viele Server gibt, alle beieinander an. Manchmal kommt da sogar eine E-Mail zurück, wenn es eben nicht klappt, weil irgendwie eine Mailbox voll ist. Und so kann halt jeder sozusagen auch das finden, was er braucht. Wenn er jetzt irgendwie viele und große E-Mails hat oder so, dann sind das sicherlich andere Anforderungen.
Also das ist ja natürlich sozusagen ein schöner Vergleich, um zu zeigen, dass Struktur, also Infrastruktur, auch so geschaltet werden kann, dass sie an verschiedenen Orten existiert. Aber der Vergleich hinkt wie alle Vergleiche, denn was man bei E-Mail kennt, das ist ja so ein Medium, was wir seit Jahrtausenden benutzen. Aber wenn auch immer jemand sich ausgenommen hat und die fragt, so Mail, sicheres Kommunikationsmedium, ganz schlimm mit dem Kopf gewogen und so, also Mail kann man eigentlich nicht vertrauen. Das ist so, das funktioniert, um so ein paar Texthäppchen zu übermitteln. Aber wenn man da vertrauenswürdige Sachen machen will, muss man ganz viel Verschlüsselung draufpacken. Und überhaupt ist das alles nicht so einfach. Das ist ein sehr gestriges Medium. Das heißt aber, übertragen der Vergleich, wir sollen, also jeder hat dann sein eigenes, kleines soziales Netzwerk, aber die müssen ja dann irgendwie miteinander kommunizieren.
Genau, das heißt, also E-Mail, der der große Unterschied in der Struktur ist, Facebook ist ein Anbieter. Das ist irgendwie ein Service, den ich da auf einer Webseite wahrnehme. Und Mail ist ein Protokoll. Das ist einfach nur ein Standard. Wie redet man miteinander?
Das heißt sozusagen, das Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerk, also das Perfekte, was vielleicht heute Abend noch entworfen wird, das ist dann erstmal gar nicht sozusagen eine reale Ausprägung, sondern erstmal eine Vereinbarung von vielen verschiedenen technikaffinen Leuten, die sagen, auf diese Art und Weise tauschen jetzt kleinere soziale Netzwerke Daten untereinander aus.
Im Grunde ja. Im Grunde funktioniert es genau so wie Mail. Und braucht nur die Übereinkunft darüber, wie man sich miteinander austauschen will und wie man sich unterhalten will.
Das hört sich doch jetzt aber wiederum so einfach an, dass man denkt, spätestens seit Facebook so groß ist, könnte doch irgendjemand mal auf die Idee gekommen sein, und sagen, geil, sowas baue ich. Das Einzige, was ich in der Richtung kenne, ist Diaspora. Und die sind ja nun seit anderthalb Jahren vom Alpha in ein Beta-Stadium gekommen, aber viel mehr ist da noch nicht passiert.
Na ja, wir sind einfach in wahnsinnig schnellen Prozessen. Und das dauert einfach, bis sich dann irgendwie Technologien sich so entwickeln, dass sie gut funktionieren. Und am Anfang haben wir oft Situationen, wo ein Spieler am Markt ist und das Ganze ziemlich dominiert. Das war beim Betriebssystem so, hat sich ein bisschen verteilt. Aber der Vergleich mag hinken. Bei anderen Beispielen ist es deutlicher. Vor 20 Jahren, als wir viele von uns über CompuSurf ins Internet gegangen sind, boten die einen internen Mailverkehr an. Jetzt wird niemand mehr auf die Idee kommen, so einen Dienst zu nutzen, weil wir eben über E-Mail zwischen verschiedenen Anbietern hin und her austauschen können, weil sich da ein Protokoll durchgesetzt hat. Und genauso kann das in anderen Bereichen auch sein. Das dauert einfach eine Zeit und da muss man vielleicht am Perspektiven von fünf bis zehn Jahren denken.
Gibt es denn da jetzt schon irgendwie einen Ansatz, dass man sagt, ja?
Absolut. Also es gibt Konzepte und es gibt auch erste Testkisten sozusagen. Diaspora hat es ja gerade schon erwähnt. Das war eine ganz spannende Initiative, denn in vielen Kreisen ist eigentlich seit zwei, drei Jahren ziemlich klar, dass man alternative Ansätze sich angucken muss. Und da waren vier Jungs, die waren gerade aus der Highschool raus und haben gesagt, wir müssen es einfach mal bauen. Und haben ins Netz eine Seite gestellt und um Spenden gebeten. Gesagt, wenn wir jetzt in 30 Tagen ungefähr 10.000 Dollar Zusage kriegen, dann fangen wir an, machen drei Monate, stecken wir in dieses Projekt rein. Naja, die hatten bis zu dem Termin 200.000 Dollar und haben sich dann gleich mit einer Firma zusammengetan, die sowas professionell macht und sitzen jetzt seit einem halben Jahr dran, sowas zu entwickeln. Und das läuft. Das läuft noch nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, es ist für jeden nutzbar, aber man kriegt so einen kleinen Einblick, wie das funktionieren kann.
Und warum ist das jetzt der einzige Versuch? Warum gibt es da nicht noch mehr? Also normalerweise, wenn so eine virulente Idee existiert, setzen sich doch irgendwie tausend Leute dran, und dann setzt sich irgendwie das Beste durch.
Es gibt unendlich viele. Diaspora ist so ein Paradebeispiel, weil das so ein bisschen Furore gemacht hat. Aber es sind da noch ganz, ganz viele Alternativen. Eines heißt Appleseed oder ein anderes heißt zum Beispiel Statusnet. Selbst Vodafone experimentiert damit. Und wenn man den Kreis weiterziehen will, dann gibt es das schon ganz lange, weil so wie E-Mail eigentlich auch ein Netzwerktool ist, um Leute in Kommunikation miteinander zu bringen. So gibt es eben eine Reihe von verschiedenen Applikationen, die im Prinzip netzwerktauglich sind und die miteinander reden und wo man sich austauscht, meistens identitätsbasiert.
Es ist ja so, dass Facebook vor allem dadurch besticht, dass es so einfach funktioniert. Das ist also momentan der einzige Dienst, wo ich persönlich sagen kann, wenn ich etwas suche im Netz, wo ich wirklich mit allen Leuten, die ich kenne, kommunizieren möchte, inklusive Großmütter und wer das alles am Start ist, dann kann das eigentlich nur Facebook sein, weil es nichts anderes gibt, was sie verstehen. Und dazu hat Facebook noch so viel. Du kannst halt nicht nur Textnachrichten austauschen, sondern auch nicht Telefonien, aber auch Bilder und Filmchen. Dann weiß er, ja er kennt man ja alles. Ist das schwierig, dann sozusagen diesen Feature-Reichtum hinzukriegen?
Auf jeden Fall aufwendig. Also ich hab die Beta von Diaspora auch mal ausprobiert, eine Zeit lang. Also die ist schon schick, die kann man bedienen, aber sehr reduziert einfach. Es gibt da nicht diese großen Klassen Features und alle möglichen jetzt noch ein Video anhängen. Und da fehlen halt einfach noch so viele Dinge, aber sie machen das, was sie tun, schon relativ schlank und schön. Und dann sind halt noch andere Fragen, die in so einer Entwicklung auch eine Rolle spielen. Wie das dann skaliert ab einer gewissen Größe, wenn es viele Server mit vielen Nutzern gibt. Das sind ja auch Dinge, die werden dann wirklich erst dann optimiert.
Der Punkt ist ja, es gibt innerhalb von Facebook eine unheimliche Vielzahl von Applikationen. Und das sind die verschiedenen Interaktionsformen, die wir da haben, die können ja auch mal über ein Spiel laufen oder sowas. Es gibt aber auch außerhalb von Facebook unheimlich viele Applikationen. Und wenn wir es schaffen, das, was Facebook am Mehrwert bietet, in diese Applikation nach draußen auch zu integrieren, dann ist das eine Alternative. Und die Frage ist, was ist der Mehrwert, der Facebook liefert? Und an vielen Stellen merkt man, dass Facebook nicht in erster Linie mehr ein soziales Netzwerk ist, sondern ein Identitätsmanagementsystem. Das heißt, im Grunde ist das ein System, wo ich mich innerhalb des Systems immer unter meiner Identität, die schlauer oder perfiderweise auch noch eigentlich nach Konvention die Klarnamenidentität ist, unter der bewege. Und das ist der Mehrwert. Wenn es gelingt, das auch ein bisschen nach draußen zu holen, dann kann da schon sehr viel passieren. Also dann ist plötzlich ein Blog, ist plötzlich eine Twitter-Wall. Und dann kannst du auf fertigen Applikationen sofort loslegen.
Aber bis dahin ist ja noch ein weiter Weg. Jetzt Dezentrales Soziales Netzwerk. Es muss leisten, dass die Leute untereinander kommunizieren können. Es muss leisten, dass eine Identität sozusagen nicht nur auf der eigenen Seite funktioniert, sondern halt netzübergreifend. Jetzt habt ihr wahrscheinlich eine Idealvorstellung davon, wie so ein Dezentrales Netzwerk aussehen soll. Wie ist die? Also was muss das alles leisten? Jetzt mal nicht dieses, damit Leute es benutzen, dazu kommen vielleicht später, sondern was muss es technisch leisten, damit ihr sagt, okay, das ist jetzt eine Art totales Netzwerk, damit bin ich zufrieden?
Also es muss freies Software sein, die sozusagen von jedem Mann und jeder Frau, wo der Quelltext offen ist, wo man sehen kann, wie sie funktioniert, wie man anpassen kann, wo man Anpassungen weitergeben, verwenden darf, auch kommerziell. Also in dem Sinne muss sie einfach komplett als Software, die existiert als Softwareprojekt, sozusagen den Standards von Linux freier Software entsprechen, dass man dem auch wirklich vertrauen kann, jeder oder misstrauen kann, wie man will und selber eben ein Auge drauf werfen kann oder eben die Kraft von vielen Leuten nutzt, das zu tun. Das hat sich auch soweit als guten Ansatz immer wieder bewährt. Und dann muss diese Software, Herrgott, am besten relativ schlank, sauber aufgeräumt sein, wenn ich mir was anpassen kann.
Und mit kommentiertem Code.
Mit kommentiertem Code bitte. Und dass man sie sehr leicht installieren kann. Dass jeder, der irgendwo vielleicht ein Webspace hat oder irgendwie einen Computer zu Hause, der irgendwie durchläuft, das einfach installieren kann und sagen kann, ich hab jetzt hier meinen Knoten am Netz. Und auch wenn der vielleicht mal einen halben Tag oder ein paar Tage offline ist, die Nachrichten trotzdem nicht verloren gehen, weil sozusagen an dem Knoten, wo sie vorhängen, sie zwischengespeichert werden.
Visionen gibt es dafür mittlerweile unheimlich viele. Eine davon wurde vor einiger Zeit von Iben Moglin, dem Hausjuristen der Free Software Foundation, an die Wand geworfen. Die entwickeln gerade mit einer neuen Stiftung, die heißt Freedom Box Foundation, einen Ansatz, wo sie sagen, wir haben hier einen kleinen Computer, der passt im Prinzip in eine Steckdose und steckt da drin. Fertig ist der Computer, den schließt man ins Internet an und da ist eben die Software drauf. Fertig. Dann hat man das bei sich zu Hause. Dann ist auf diesem Steckdosencomputer, Schieverplug, ist dann im Prinzip die Software für einen kompletten sozialen Netzwerkserver, der mit anderen Knotenpunkten im Netz kommunizieren kann. Und ich hab den bei mir.
Gibt es da schon eine Preisnummer?
Eine Preisnummer. Also diese Schieverplugs gibt es tatsächlich recht billig. Die kosten so um die 100 Dollar. Mittlerweile gibt es aber auch interessante Konzepte, die noch viel günstiger vom kompletten Computer anbieten können. Also über Größenordnung 25 oder 17 Dollar oder sowas. Und da könnte das im Prinzip darauf stattfinden. Voraussetzung ist natürlich, und da ist sehr zu Recht gelacht gerade, dass das schlank und sauber programmiert ist. Und da sind im Moment auch große Herausforderungen, glaube ich.
Das schaffen wir noch nicht. Aber das ist das wirklich so sagen, das Endziel, sag ich mal, dieser Forderung nach einem dezentralen Netzwerk, dass das wirklich jeder zu Hause macht. Also im Prinzip, dass man sich dahin versteigt und sagt, jede Person hat den eigenen Rechner in der Steckdose, der das macht.
Also ideal finde ich schon das Konzept von physikalischer Kontrolle. Ich finde das schon ziemlich cool. Also zu sagen, ich muss einen Stecker ziehen und kann dadurch sehen, das kann nicht mehr verbunden sein, was da drauf ist im Netz. Das kann ja kopiert an anderer Stelle auch nochmal vorliegen, aber das, wo ich weiß, das ist in aggregierten zugreifbaren Formen, nur so dort, kann ich ziehen. Das ist irgendwie ein ganz cooles Feature. Das finde ich sehr spannend. Es muss aber nicht so sein, und für viele Anwendungen und auch für Übergangszeiten ist es sicherlich wichtig und sinnvoll, dass es flexibel ist, dass Sachen beim Hostel liegen können, dass ich das quasi auslagern kann und das nicht bei mir unbedingt haben muss. Möglicherweise können sich auch viele Leute zusammentun und erstmal einen gemeinsamen Server betreiben. So läuft das bei Diaspora. Aber diese Server können auch miteinander reden. Das ist nicht nur ein System.
Da kommen wir zur spannenden Frage. Wenn ich das in Zukunft installieren will, ist ja, wenn es diese kleinen Computer gäbe, dann gäbe es die wahrscheinlich auch von verschiedenen Anbietern. Wenn wir jetzt nicht vom Hacker reden, der sich den erst selber zusammenlötet und dann auch noch selber die Software aufspielt, würde man das kaufen. Da müsste man ja schon wieder irgendwie Vertrauen haben. Und das wird ja noch schlimmer oder die Vertrauensforderung noch größer. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwo hingehe und sage, ich benutze jetzt zwar nicht den zentralen Facebook-Knoten, aber ich benutze doch den Knoten eines anderen Menschen. Wie stellt sich das vor? Haben dann sozusagen alle Leute gehen zu den Hausnörzern, lassen sie das machen?
Na, es gibt ja unterschiedliche Vertrauenskonzepte. Eine schöne Definition ist immer zu sagen, Vertrauen ist da, wo Sicherheit nicht ist. Das ist eine gängige Definition bei der CIA zum Beispiel. Und wenn man das annimmt, dann muss man doch sagen, für den Facebook-Teil im Moment habe ich da nur Vertrauen als Rundlage und keine Sicherheit. Wenn ich physikalischen Stecker ziehen kann, oder zumindest wenn das beim Freundlich bei dem den Stecker ziehen könnte, dann habe ich ein Element, was mir tatsächlich Sicherheit gewährt. Zumindest in dem Sinn Sicherheit, dass ich davon ausgehen kann, dass Bits und Bytes jetzt nicht plötzlich vom Ethernet-Kabel auf die Buchse durch die Luft hüpfen können. Und da bin ich ziemlich sicher.
Aber es ist schon sozusagen, weil mit diesem Versprechen eines anderen dezentralen Ansatzes verbinden ja vielleicht dann manche Leute auch so, dass ist dann ein sicheres soziales Netzwerk. Das wird weiterhin aber nicht der Fall sein. Das ist sozusagen das perfekte, sichere, wo ich meine Daten ausknipsen kann, dann sind sie weg.
Das sollte man auf jeden Fall vielleicht auch in der Struktur mit bedenken, wie man sowas aufbaut, dass z.B. so was wie Verschlüsselung auch ein Standardelement ist. Und dass jede Nachrichten, die ich über dieses Netzwerk transferiere, die eben privaten Charakter haben, auch wirklich sicher verschlüsselt sind, von meinem Ende als Sender bis zum Ende des Empfängers. Und dass diese Protokolle dafür möglichst die besten Vorgierungen treffen, dass das der Fall ist.
Aber es wird nach wie vor so sein, dass du sagen, ich stelle etwas in ein soziales Netzwerk und damit kennt es der ganze Kreis und kann es im Zweifel auch kopieren. Also es ist nicht so, wenn ich jetzt einen Stecker rausziehe, dass dann alle Daten, die ich uns reingestellt habe, weg sind.
Es gibt keinen digitalen Radiergummi an der Stelle und Daten... Auch wenn ich bei Facebook einstelle, dürfen nur meine Freunde sehen, kann immer noch ein Freund von mir, ein Freund, in Anführungszeichen, gleich hingehen und sagen, ich kopiere das hier raus und stelle das jetzt mal irgendwie auf meinen öffentlichen Sonstewass-Account, Webseite und so. Klar, also da ist Sicherheit immer relativ und Vertrauen ist dann ein interessanter Aspekt, weil was gibt mir einen Grund zu vertrauen, zu einem Markt, der meistens nur aus einer Hand voll von Firmen besteht. Meistens irgendwelche schick angezogenen Werbemodels. Vertrauen findet auf zwei Ebenen statt. Zum einen, dass es funktioniert und zum anderen, dass es auch integer und sicher ist. Und wenn da jemand oder, was weiß ich, ob jetzt eine Polizei kommt oder ein Hacker, der Hacker hat einfach mal eher die Motivation, der großen Datensatz knacken will, dass der möglichst groß ist. Und wenn ich dann meine E-Mails bei GMX habe, dann ist es sozusagen wie Dezentrale. Man kann sich aussuchen, ob man wenig große Datenberge hat in diesem Internet oder viele kleine. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, wenn ein großer gehackt wird, dass dann einfach mal ein nennenswerter Anteil an Menschen da auch unter diesem Datenverlust potenziell leiden kann, was heißt Verlust, das ist Übermachung von Daten, ist dann einfach mal viel größer. Insofern ist das Dezentrale an sich, auch wenn es vielschichtig ist. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass alle dieselbe Software haben, sondern auf demselben Protokoll arbeiten. Es gibt ja auch verschiedenste Mail-Clients. Es gibt, was heißt ich, in der Windows den Outlook, es gibt den Thunderbird, der zum Firefox dazu kommt. Und so kann man sich für den Server entscheiden und für eine Software. Die Software kann für alle möglichen Systeme angepasst werden. Und das ist einfach schon ein Weg, wie alle Beteiligten an solchen Prozessen, da wirklich die Kontrolle drüber und die Herrschaft haben. Das ist natürlich auch etwas, das große Unternehmen oder Staaten interessiert.
Also die Frage, die sich mir gerade aufdrängt, ist ja, dass die Sicherheit nur dann gegeben ist, wenn diese Dinge immer aktuell sind. Also was du ja sagst, ist quasi, die sind nicht mehr so lohnenswerte Ziele, weil es gibt da nicht diesen riesigen Datenhaufen. Das heißt, wenn, dann wäre es wahrscheinlich ein gezielter Angriff. Oder, was auch wieder der Fall sein könnte, wenn diese kleinen Server von Firmen verkauft werden, sozusagen und jeder hat so ein Ding zu Hause und es stellt sich heraus, es gibt eine Sicherheitslücke, die man automatisiert benutzen kann, dann hat man doch wieder den großen Datenhaufen, weil man die alle ausliest. Gibt es denn da schon so eine Vorstellung für, wie dieses Sicherheitskonzept gewährleistet wird?
Das klingt ja so, wenn du sagst, wenn Firmen verkauft werden, dann ist das ja jetzt eben nicht, weil es ja freie Software ist, diese schwarze Kiste, der ich anvertrauen muss, und damit kann ich nichts tun, es ist ja freie Software. Also es geht ja einfach nur um, ich hab einen Computer und da tue ich eine Software drauf. Kaufe ich mir halt so einen Computer und dann ist da die Software noch gar nicht mal drauf. Oder vielleicht verkauft sie auch jemand mit der Software schon drauf, aber ich kann sie immer selber drauf tun, austauschen. Es ist eine freie Software, wo viele Leute drauf schauen, wie es funktioniert. Und klar, die muss dann auch aktuell gehalten werden, wenn Sicherheitslücken bekannt werden. Aber dadurch, dass es eben eine freie Software ist, schauen da viel mehr Leute drauf, können drauf schauen und sagen, da ist eine Lücke, dann wird die auch sofort bekannt und repariert.
Also das mit dem sofort repariert könnte man auch nochmal.
Also Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke sind nicht geeignet dazu, sämtliche Sicherheitslücken des Netzes zu beseitigen. Das kann nicht. Der Ansatz, den Wetter gerade gesagt hat, vertreten hat, der ist genau richtig, dass du es wirklich verteilst. Dann entstehen eine ganze Menge Probleme nicht, die du mit großen Datenhalden schon hast. Insbesondere hast du auch nicht so sehr große Akteure, die über diese Datenhalden verfügen. Und die machen den Bestand ja im Prinzip unkontrollierbar. Interessanterweise ist das auch einer der zentralen Punkte, die Morglen da aufbringt zu sagen, wir können uns das als Gesellschaft gar nicht leisten, dass wir so einen zentralen Player haben wie Facebook, der komplett dein Verhalten für acht Stunden am Tag mehr oder weniger mitschneidet, dein Interaktionskommunikationsverhalten und die Daten auswerten kann. Weil die Manipulationsanfälligkeit unter Umständen genau ganz groß ist. Und da reicht unter Umständen schon das Gefühl, dass du sagst, da ist irgendwas, was möglicherweise manipulierend eingreifen kann. Das muss gar nicht wirklich passieren, aber es macht dadurch einen Impact und verändert Gesellschaft. Das heißt, du hörst auf auch in Demokratie zu vertrauen und so weiter. Das ist echt so ein bisschen das rechtliche Fundament dahinter. Die Dezentralität auf der anderen Seite war ja schon eine Grundstruktur des Netzes ganz am Anfang. Das ist glaube ich Teil des Erfolgsmodells. Und deswegen bin ich auch ganz sicher, dass das kommen wird in der einen oder anderen Form. Es ist aber echt eine Frage von Zeit. Also es kann schon eine Weile dauern.
Und nochmal zu sagen, zurück zu diesem Sicherheitsding. Was ich mich gerade frage ist, es gibt dann sozusagen diese vielen kleinen Instanzen und es gibt dann das Bekanntwerter eine Sicherheitslücke. Und wir wollen mal also realistischerweise davon ausgehen, dass nicht alle sofort hinlaufen und irgendwie ihr System patchen. Gibt es dann so eine Überlegung, dass man Kommunikationsstrukturen so baut, dass Knoten in diesem Netz nicht miteinander reden, wenn sie nicht die aktuellste Version haben oder sowas? Also gibt es da Gedanken, um genau dieses Problem abzufallen, was es ja geben wird?
Auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee. An der Stelle ist es vielleicht so zu lösen, aber vielleicht eher eine automatische Aktualisierungsroutine, die die Systeme, wenn man als Nutzer dem System erlaubt, sich selber aktualisieren, wenn eben eine Sicherheitslücke und die Möglichkeit zu schließen bekannt geworden ist. Ansonsten wollte ich da noch so ein kleines Bild bringen zu, wir reden ja nicht nur von vielen verschiedenen Servern, sondern auch, dass eben viele verschiedene Software darauf laufen kann. Und da kann ja jeder, der irgendwie der Software nicht traut, selber eine machen. Ja, und da wird automatisch eben diese Diversität auch an verschiedene Server-Software womöglich geben und Client-Software. Und das ist auch in dem Sinne metaphorisch verglichen so mal mit, sagen wir mal, Landwirtschaft. Ja, Moment, pass auf, pass auf. Wenn jetzt alle sozusagen die selbe Getreidesorte anbauen würden, von derselben Monsanto, whatever Firma. Und dann gibt es da einmal ein Virus, der sich schnell verbreitet und alle Erntenbefälter sind natürlich auch schnell alle, wenn alle überall dieselben sind, das schnell weitergetragen, dieser Virus. Und da sozusagen eine Diversifizierung, die einfach möglich ist durch ein Protokoll, dass verschiedene Leute Software programmieren können. Auch wie der System immanent, Struktur immanent, ein Sicherheitsfeature, weil eine Sicherheitslücke in der Regel erstmal nur für eine bestimmte Software geht.
Das heißt also, systemweit ist das System ein bisschen stabiler, aber den Einzelnen kannst du natürlich immer noch treffen?
Na klar, es gibt nie 100%ige Sicherheit und es können Lücken in deinem Betriebssystem auftreten, in den Programmiersprachen, die verwendet worden sind. Wähler der Leute, die die Programme geschrieben haben.
Oder absichtlich, das frage ich mich gar nicht.
Oder absichtlich, so. Und das hat diese Sache, kann ich einem Unternehmen vertrauen, dass es nicht vielleicht irgendwie korrumpiert ist oder irgendwie erpresst wird? Und wenn ich halt diesen Quelltext dahinter, dieses freie Softwareansatz nicht sehen kann, dann kann ich nicht sicher gehen, nicht paranoid sein und sozusagen Zeile für Zeile den Programmtext durchgehen und gucken, was er mit meinen Daten macht. Da muss ich irgendwie vertrauen. Und deswegen ist dieser freie Softwareansatz zu sagen, dass nicht nur das Protokoll offen ist, man kann natürlich auch nicht offene Software für dieses Protokoll schreiben, aber ich würde sie nicht benutzen. Das wäre dann witzlos an der Stelle.
Aber du müsstest dann auch verbieten, dass dein Knoten mit Knoten redet, die nicht offene Software benutzen.
Das wäre eine schöne Idee, auf jeden Fall.
Okay, sehr diffizil. Ich frage mich, ob meine Großkundin das verstehen würde. Jan, gibt's jetzt Wort. Wir machen jetzt erst mal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und dann geht's hier gleich weiter beim Chaosradio.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Keine Sperrungen des Internets in Deutschland. Die Bundesregierung hat sich endgültig von der umstrittenen Zensurinfrastruktur verabschiedet, die Seiten geblockt hat, auf denen sexuelle Handlungen an Kindern gezeigt werden. Im Zukunft werde löschen statt Sperren bevorzugt. Telekom beabsichtigt zwei Klassen Internet. Mit sogenannten Serviceklassen will die Telekom Qualität sichern. Man suche das Gespräch mit verkehrsintensiven Anbietern wie YouTube, um über die Bezahlung der Verwaltung größerer Datenströme zu reden. Bitte achten Sie auf alle Einschränkungen, die sich daraus für Sie als Endkunden ergeben können. Netzneutralität für niederländische Datenautobahnen.
Der Wirtschafts-
und Innovationsminister Maxime Verhagen kündigte einen Gesetzentwurf an, der einen freien Zugang zum Internet sicherstellen soll. Auch sollen Mobilfunkanbieter die Nutzung von Internettelefonien nicht unterbinden dürfen. Wir wünschen allen Datenreisenden eine angenehme Anbindung.
Heute mit Markus Richter, außerdem Wetter Frosch vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio und Jan Schallerböck. Und die sind hier, um über Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke zu reden. Ganz kurz in zwei Sätzen für Leute, die jetzt gerade das eingeschaltet haben. Was sind Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke?
Der Versuch vom Privacy freundlichen Facebook ohne zentralen Akteure.
Und zwar wer macht das dann?
Jeder selbst, kurz gesagt.
Und was sind die Probleme, die man hat schon alleine, wenn es darum geht, wer das wie veranstalten soll?
Wenn alles in einer Hand liegt, dann hat man auch einen Punkt, wo ein Fehler sich großartig auswirken kann.
Genau, und wenn es in mehreren Händen liegt, darüber hatten wir gerade gesprochen, ist das System an sich zwar stabiler, aber der einzelne Punkt muss natürlich trotzdem sichergestellt werden. Und genau dazu wolltest du noch was vor den Nachrichten sagen. Hast du das noch im Kopf oder möglicherweise aufgeschrieben?
Hab ich nicht, aber das kann ich frei improvisieren. Die Frage der Angreifbarkeit bleibt bestehen. Das kann man nicht ändern. Das wird sukzessive besser werden, aber es werden auch weiter neue Angriffe entwickelt werden. Das kriegen wir nicht weg. Wir kriegen aber ein paar Punkte total architektonische Veränderung, die andere Angriffe unmöglich machen und andere möglich. Also es verändert sich da was. Und ich glaube, dass die Art der Angriffe, die dann möglich bleibt, überschaubarer ist als gesellschaftliches und individuelles Risiko.
Jetzt haben wir Patrick, der Angriffe hat. Das könnt ihr übrigens auch tun unter 0331709720. Und der hat Erfahrungen gesammelt mit einem dieser Dezentrale sozialen Netzwerke, eines der größeren, die schon ausprobiert werden können, nämlich Diaspora. Und jetzt ist er am Telefon. Hallo Patrick. Was genau hast du denn mit Diaspora zu tun?
Ja, ich hab da, sag ich mal, angefangen, damit, dass ich einfach mal in dieses Netzwerk reingegangen bin. Das lief über Twitter. Diaspora ist jetzt fertig. Ich hab schon vorher gesehen, dass die drei Jungs da was entwickeln wollen. Und es hörte sich für mich echt super an. Ich hab das im HLS den Musicer gelesen und war auf Twitter eben. Und ich hab mir die Videos angeguckt und fand das eigentlich echt klasse, dass endlich mal Daten, Verschlüsse ausgetauscht werden, dass man sehr selbstbestimmt arbeiten kann. Man hat da Aspekte in die man postet. Das heißt, man kann sehr selektiv sagen, wer darf das sehen, wer darf nicht sehen. Und kann dann halt quasi an Leute was schicken, die man kennt, die man weniger gut kennt. Oder halt an alle. Oder man kann halt nach Twitter posten und nach Facebook, wenn man das will. Kann man aber auch ausschalten. Das ist schon eine ganz, ganz klasse Sache. Die Bilder, die man postet, beispielsweise sind verschlüsselt mit einem Algorithmus, mit einem GPG-Algorithmus. Und damit kann halt nur derjenige das sehen, der das soll. Also beispielsweise habe ich das öfters mal gesehen, dass Leute öffentlich Fotos von ihren Kindern posten. Und sowas gehört eigentlich nicht in die Öffentlichkeit, sondern halt in die Trivats.
Du hast Diaspora also selber ausprobiert und bist begeistert?
Ich bin relativ begeistert. Das Einzige, was vielleicht fehlt, ist der Retweet-Button, den es halt bei Twitter gibt. Übrigens muss ich euch korrigieren, die ist nicht in der Beta. Die Diaspora ist in der Alpha. Geht aber in die Beta über.
Richtig.
Und ich hab's auch installiert. Und das geht auch sehr, sehr reibungsfrei, wenn man die Anleitung korrekt liest.
Das heißt, du hast, muss man zu sagen, hast du sagen, so einen Server bei dir installiert. Und bist du nur du, bist du nur du, bist nur du darauf unterwegs oder auch noch andere Leute?
Es sind, auf, beispielsweise, es gibt halt einen deutschen Server, also einen deutschen Protz.
Nein, nein, auf den, den du installiert hast, sind da noch andere Leute unterwegs?
Derzeit nicht, nee. Also, das war jetzt auch nur mal eine Spielgespielerei zu gucken. Es geht gut zu installieren.
Wen würdest du denn da rauflassen? Also, was müsste jemand mitbringen, der sagt, kann ich bitte deinen Port benutzen?
Naja, der ist nicht öffentlich, der ist, sag ich mal, net intern. Aber im Prinzip habe ich mit dem Gedanken gespielt, auch selber einen Port anzulegen. Das ist halt immer eine Kostenfrage, nicht? Man muss halt irgendwie einen Server haben, den man betreiben muss.
Okay, muss das ja nicht öffentlich tun. Du kannst ja auch, also, wärst du denn bereit, Freunden oder Bekannten einen Account auf deinem Server zu geben?
Das könnte man machen, ja.
Okay, Patrick hat also Diaspora ausprobiert und ist sehr begeistert davon. Einen Port hat er auch sich selber installiert, aber, sagt er, ist er erst mal nur für ihn so. Für andere möchte man das nicht zur Verfügung stellen. Wir haben jetzt noch jemand hier, der sich Kloschi nennt. Und ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig ausgesprochen. Und der betreibt so ein Ding in einer etwas größeren Variante. Da seid auch ihr unterwegs auf dem seinen sozusagen Knoten für Diaspora. So, und ihr seid jetzt bei ihm unterwegs?
Richtig, ja.
Und ihr vertraut ihm da auch?
Wir nutzen das. Und probieren das damit aus. Wir sind einfach in einer Testphase mit dem Ganzen.
Okay, Kloschi, du hast dich dazu entschieden, sowas zu installieren. Jetzt meinte Patrick gerade, das kann man nicht umsonst machen, aber man braucht noch einen ordentlichen Server für. Wie viel Geld hast du da rein investiert?
Also Geld hab ich da gar keins rein investiert. Das läuft halt auf dem root Server, den ich eh mit ein paar Leuten für verschiedene Zwecke betreibe. Und da haben wir eine eigene VM und mit zwei CPUs und 750 MB RAM läuft das Ding stabil.
Also ihr habt eh großes Spielzeug rumzulegen und habt dann da ein bisschen was abgeknapst? Wie einfach war es denn das Ding in Betrieb zu nehmen?
Also da ich das quasi beim Release der ersten Alpha direkt an Start gebracht hab, war das alles noch ein bisschen hakelig. Wer sich mit Rails auskennt, damals war die einzige Möglichkeit, das Diaspora in der Development Umgebung auszuführen. Zwischendrin hat man dann für produktive Pods auf die Production Umgebung umgestellt. Da hatte ich dann einen riesengroßen Fu, die Datenbank zu migrieren und so weiter. Also der Weg von dem ersten Alpha Release bis heute war nicht schmerzfrei. Allerdings muss man sagen, dass es sich inzwischen sehr einfach maintainen lässt, wenn man ein paar Command Line Kenntnisse hat.
Okay, also mal kurz zusammengefasst, für die Normal User kurz übersetzen. Es ist noch schwierig zu installieren. Man muss sich auf der Kommandozeile ein bisschen auskennen, um das zu machen.
Nur ein bisschen. Also inzwischen kann man durchaus, wenn man sich ein bisschen reindenkt und dem How-To folgt, einen eigenen Port aufsetzen, insofern man in der Lage ist, einen DNS-Server zu konfigurieren und Main-Namen auf eine IP zeigen zu lassen, immerhin. Wenn man das hinbekommt, dann kann man den Port laufen lassen.
Okay, ich frag mal kurz ins Studio. Mittlerweile ist noch jemand angekommen. Genja, den wir gleich noch ausführlich begrüßen werden, erheb mal bitte die Hände. Wer konnte jetzt aus dem Stehgreif nach den Vorgaben, die Kloschi gerade gemacht hat, so ein Ding installieren? Hand heben? Eine geht hoch, zwei geht hoch, dritt geht nicht hoch. Also halbe halbe. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein sehr...
Also, B-Tool und ein paar Befehle und eine Konjunktdata editieren, das Ding hochschießen, das geht schon. Also, wenn man sich da ein bisschen mit Foren und How-Tos und der IRC-Channel... Es gibt, wie vorhin hab ich gerade im Raute Chaos Radio gesehen, auch einen raute diaspora-.de. Da gibt es auch sehr hilfsbereite Menschen, die zu jeder Auskunft, zu jeder Zeit in der Lage sind. Also, man kann das schon machen.
Also, sagen, wenn man das will, kann man das machen. Was glaubst du, wie weit diaspora noch entfernt ist von... Das kann jetzt wirklich jeder. Mindestens Monate. Wird das da jemals hinkommen?
Allerdings hab ich auch meine ganz eigene Sicht auf die ganze Dezentralisierungsdebatte, die ihr da auch da die ganze Zeit geführt habt. Denn für mich sind diaspora und Appleseed und Kimbell, und wie sie alle heißen, nur ein weiterer Schritt in Richtung des richtigen Ziels. Weil im Grunde machen wir mit diaspora und all den anderen Sachen ja nichts anderes als eine Aufteilung von einer Zentrale auf viele Zentralen. Und das perspektivisch wirklich sinnvolle Ziel kann nur sein, wirklich dezentrale Inhalte zu haben, dezentralen Content. Das klingt wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen abstrakt, und so richtig in einen Draft schreiben könnte ich das auch noch nicht. Aber wenn da mal ein paar Leute perspektivisch die Köpfe zusammenstecken, kann man da durchaus zu Lösungen kommen.
Du sagst also auch, das Endziel der Dezentralisierung ist quasi der kleine Computer, der bei mir zu Hause in einem Steckdoser steckt?
Ja, oder auf mein mobilen Endgerät, wenn ich dort auf Verschlüsselung vertrauen kann und dem Betriebssystem vertrauen kann, oder, oder, oder.
Aber das ist ein interessanter Aspekt, diese Teilung zwischen mehreren Zentralen oder wirklich einem Peer-to-Peer-Ansatz, wo wirklich jeder gleichermaßen Senderempfänger ist, wo es nicht mehr dieses Server client Nutzer und Anbieter Modell gibt, sondern einfach jeder gleichermaßen Nutzer und Anbieter ist, Nachrichten weiterleitet, weiter schickt und jeder Computer quasi Miniserver. Und das dann traumhafterweise auch noch so funktioniert, dass man den einfach mal auszuschalten, wo man das wieder aufklappen kann und keine Nachrichten verloren gehen. Das aber alles verschlüsselt ist. Also Toschi, das siehst du auch so, oder?
Und ich glaube auch, dass es nicht die Frage des Endgerätes ist. Es wird doch viele, viele Varianten von Endgeräten geben, sei es die Variation von Freedom Box, wie eben Moglen und die Foundation das jetzt beschreibt, sei es einfach nur eine App auf einem hoffentlich noch freieren mobilen Betriebssystem als Android, das gerade ist, oder sei es einfach auch nur eine gewisse Art von Virtualisierung, sodass jeder Mensch jederzeit in der Lage ist, sich eine Identität in Form eines dezentralen Social Knoten, was auch immer, hoch zu schießen und darüber einfach auch die Verfügungsgewalt hat im Sinne Sicherheit, Abschaltbarkeit, im Sinne was auch immer. Der richtige Weg auf jeden Fall ist im Moment die Dezentralisierung von einer auf viele Zentralen, wie wir das mit den Pods ja auch gerade machen. Ich habe im IRC gesagt bekommen, dass zum Beispiel der große deutsche Pod, das Geraspora, dass die zurzeit 8000 Nutzer drauf haben auf dem Alpha-Diaspora, also das ist beachtlich. Aber perspektivisch geht es natürlich drum, dass die Instanzen, ob das jetzt ein Diaspora, einen Status nennt oder irgendwas, wie heißen die, Buddy Cloud und so weiter, da gibt es ja ganz viel inzwischen, XMPP-basierte und so weiter, wenn die einfach auf einer vernünftigen Art hier miteinander reden können. Und dann sind wir langsam da, wo wir hingehen wollen, glaube ich.
Jetzt zum Abschluss noch eine Frage. Du hast ja auch ein paar User auf dem Pod, also diesem Diaspora-Teil, den du bei dir betreibst, ein paar User. Wie viele sind das?
Also der Pod ist eigentlich nur zu Test-Checken und zu Freunde aufgesetzt gewesen. Im Laufe der Zeit haben immer mal Leute angefragt, ob sie einen Account haben können. Lassen wir es mal über die Zeit um die 15 bis 20 Leute gewesen sein. Und da jeder von denen fünf weitere Einladungen hatte. Und ich habe gestern noch mal geschaut, im Moment sind es um die 75 Nutzer. Das heißt keine öffentliche Subscription. Und trotzdem hat sich das so ganz langsam auf 75 Nutzer aufgebaut. Und ich glaube, wenn man da die Tür aufmacht, dann ist man ganz schnell bei ein paar tausend. Das will man natürlich eigentlich nicht.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade fragen. Ab welcher Stelle würdest du sagen, jetzt ist genug, jetzt mache ich zu, bau dir selber was?
Der relevante Punkt ist, ich habe einfach keine Lust, Verantwortung für die Datensicherheit von Leuten zu übernehmen, die ich nicht kenne. Ich betreibe Server und Dienste unter Datensicherheitsaspekten, wie ich sie für mich für richtig halte, für enge Freunde beispielsweise. Aber wenn da jetzt Leute dabei sind, die einfach weniger oder nicht so nahe sind im Freundeskreis oder so, ist mir das einfach auch viel zu viel Verantwortung. Also ich möchte privat nicht die Verantwortung für die Datensicherheit von Leuten übernehmen, die mir jetzt nicht sehr nahe sind. Deswegen glaube ich, dass so ab einer Nutzverzahl von 200, 300 werde ich dann irgendwann einfach sagen, so liebe Leute, ich hoffe, ihr habt genügend getestet und wer Hilfe braucht, einen Pod aufzusetzen, gerne hier. Aber ich würde jetzt einfach gerne einen neuen Pod aufsetzen mit nur Freunden und da darf auch keiner keinen einladen, sondern das sind halt nur wir. Also es hat halt ein bisschen was mit Privacy einerseits zu tun und auf der anderen Seite auch mit Verantwortung als Serverbetreiber.
Umgegrenzt geht es also nicht, soll es auch gar nicht, die Dezentrale Netzwerksklosche auf jeden Fall. Vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch und lass dich nicht von deinen Usern ärgern. So, außerdem, jetzt neu im Studio zugekommen, Genja, den ich persönlich also gar nicht kenne. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum er hier ist. Das muss er uns jetzt nämlich ganz einfach mal selber erklären. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Du kommst, tun wir das Mikro noch ein bisschen zu dir ran? Nee, oben an dem Schwenkarm? Nee, an dem Metallteil. On-Air Mikrofon-Shootung. Wir sind zwischendurch nicht dazu gekommen, weil er gerade sozusagen hier während der Sendung hineingestürzt ist. Was ihr gerade hört, ist sozusagen die Zurechtrückung des Mikrofons. So, jetzt noch mal Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo und guten Abend.
Wer bist du und was machst du hier?
Ich bin Genja. Ich bin hier, um eigentlich so ein bisschen die Nutzer-Seite zu repräsentieren. Denn eigentlich ist es ja so, dass das Netz, die Software, die Pakete, die Funktionen, die wir dort haben, immer sich an dem orientieren, was eigentlich die Menschen da draußen, und zwar die normalen Menschen, die eben nicht DNS konfigurieren können, tatsächlich auch benutzen. Denn wenn alle meine Freunde tatsächlich einen eigenen Pod konfigurieren können, dann können wir das ja heute schon alles machen. Aber heute ist es noch nicht so weit, dass wir sagen können, die Software hat abgehoben. Und ich bin da so ein bisschen, also wir sitzen jetzt hier gerade zu dritt auf einer Seite, und das stellt auch so ein bisschen diese Rechts-Links-Mitte-Position dar. Ich bin eher so ein bisschen der soziale Aspekt, und wann hat das Ding tatsächlich eine Relevanz und eine Beantwortung der User-Bedürfnisse? Und ganz rechts haben wir dann die technische Seite, die dann extrem auf Datensicherheit, Kryptographie etc.
So könnte man ein schönes Diagramm der Gäste heute hier in der Sendung machen. Ein sogenanntes Technik-Gefälle von links nach rechts, und es ist dann auch ein Sozial-Gefälle von rechts nach links. Nein! Darüber wollen wir nicht, um Gottes willen. Wie zufrieden bist du denn mit Diaspora aus Usersicht? Also ich mein schon der Name ist ja schrecklich, man kann es kaum aussprechen, weil die Betonung kann ich mir überhaupt nicht merken.
Ja, Diaspora hat ja auch so eine Konnotation im kulturgeschäftlichen Raum, aber die war glaube ich nicht gewünscht oder geplant. Die Frage ist halt, wenn ich, also wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, Identitäten. Wenn ich eine Identität habe, zielgerichtet bei Facebook, ist es eigentlich die Realnamen-Identität, die echte Identität. Hypothetisch gibt es ja Kreise, die dann schon eine Authentifizierung mit dem neuen E-Perso im Internet fordern. Also das wäre ja sozusagen so der Albtraum irgendwie aller Anwesenden.
Twitter bietet es doch mehr oder weniger schon fast an. Studio VZ ist gerade in Verhandlung mit dem Innenministerium. Dann kannst du deine Authenticated Identity dort abholen.
Hast du gerade Twitter bietet das schon angesagt?
Die bieten qualifiziert Authenticated Identities an. Die haben noch keine E-Perso Schnittstellen, machen das im Moment über Post Ident.
Aber ich dachte bei denen geht es eher um die Stars und Sternchen, damit die sich verifizieren können. Aber die wollen das nicht verpflichtend einführen.
Du kannst es als Feature einführen. Dann hast du so eine kleine Banderole auf deinem Avatar.
Schwarz-Rot-Gold.
Wer das liest ist doof.
Authenticated. Ich bin es wirklich.
Ich schlage vor, ihr denkt nicht mehr was aus, um das System zu hacken. Ich möchte gerne das Datenschaf sein.
Genau, aber zurück. Das wäre sozusagen das Extrem. Also die erzwungene Realnamenidentität in allen Netzen überlagend. Und das andere Extrem ist eben Tausende von Online-Identitäten, die alle flach sind, weil die in der Komplexität, die es erfordert, eine Falschidentität sozusagen aufrechtzuerhalten, da braucht es wirklich Zeit und Aufwand. Also Paris Hilton oder fake Steve Jobs, das sind ja Leute, die wirklich nichts anderes mehr als Hobby machen, als diese Fake-Identität zu erhalten. Und irgendwo dazwischen liegt die Wahrheit. Die Frage ist eben, wenn ich meine Freunde suche, wie finde ich sie? Und das ist eine ganz zentrale Frage. Bei einem Player ist es absolut keine Frage, ob ich sie finde, wenn sie gefunden werden wollen. Dann frage ich sie, wie heißt du? Ich bin eigentlich Jonas, heiße aber Weißes Kaninchen bei Facebook. Da musst du mich einfach nur suchen und somit habe ich den gefunden. Wie schaffe ich das über eine verteilte, kryptografisch auch gesicherte Kommunikation von mehreren Teilnehmern, die vielleicht alle behaupten, sie sind das Weiße Kaninchen? Also welches Weiße Kaninchen ist in dem Fall das Richtige?
Also meine spontane Antwort wäre, naja, du fragst sie natürlich genau, wie bei Facebook auch im richtigen Leben wir dort heißen und fragst sie an. Die Herren und Damen vom Technikgefälle ein bisschen weiter oben. Wie ist das gelöst?
Es gibt eine gesellschaftliche und eine technische Antwort. Beziehungsweise sind gesellschaftliche und technische Aufgabenstellungen. Das eine ist Social Search als als Feature in dezentrale Systeme reinzukriegen. Das ist keine triviale Aufgabe, aber zum Beispiel sitzen da meines Wissens Leute in Cambridge dran, die darüber promovieren. Das ist noch nicht 100 Prozent gelöst, aber dezentrale Suchmaschinen gibt es schon ein paar Modelle dafür und Peer to Peer Search läuft auch irgendwie. Jedenfalls in Peer to Peer Tauschbörsen gibt es da Ansätze, die man wieder verwenden. Das ist die technische Sicht. Schwieriger ist der soziale Punkt. Natürlich, und das ist der Netzwerkeffekt, den haben andere Systeme auch. Wenn du innen System nicht dezentral reinkommunizieren kannst, wie das an vielen Stellen bei Facebook noch der Fall ist, auch wenn die zunehmend Schnittstellen einbauen, dann ist natürlich klar, musst du bei Facebook sein, um mit dieser Community zu kommunizieren. Und die ist riesig groß, deswegen fast nicht sozusagen reinzukommen. Deswegen war die Gründer von einem anderen großen Netzwerk auch sehr stolz, diesen Effekt erreicht zu haben, konnten das sehr teuer verkaufen. Das ist richtig was wert. Scheinbar sind da Leute bereit, für richtig viel Geld auszugeben. Aber der hat sich wirklich gefreut, weil er dachte, er hat den perfekten Login. Und dann kam ein paar Jahre Facebook und man sieht Migration. Und das mit dem Login, das wird nicht so einfach funktionieren.
Du musst, glaube ich, mal kurz Login erklären, weil es ist nicht ein Login, dass man sich irgendwo einloggt, sondern Login ist was anderes.
Login bedeutet an der Stelle, dass man eingesperrt ist in dem Netzwerk, dass man da nicht raus kann, wenn man nicht seine Freunde verlieren will sozusagen. Und zumindest diese Interaktionsmöglichkeit mit Freunden nicht verlieren will. Und dadurch glaubt man, dass man, wenn man einmal den Markt aufgeteilt hat, dass einem das Ding gehört. Das Problem ist, dass die Leute durchaus in der Lage sind, jetzt schon mehrere soziale Netzwerke zu betreuen, zu nutzen und zu pflegen. Neben Facebook macht jeder mittlerweile auf jeden Fall... E-Mail hab ich mir sagen lassen. Aber daneben eben auch noch eine ganze Reihe von weiteren. Und dass es zusätzlich noch so ein Kohortenverhalten gibt. Das heißt, alle sieben Jahre ändert sich das soziale Umfeld ziemlich komplett, zumindest in den ersten 28 Jahren. Und das kann man dann weiterspinnen bis zu den viel beschworenen Silversurfern. Und in diesen Zeitabschnitten baust du ein komplett neues soziales Umfeld aus. Und in deren Abschnitten kann sich sowas auch komplett erneuern. Das heißt, wenn jemand jetzt mit Diaspora anfängt und sagt, okay, die Leute kann ich nur über Diaspora erreichen oder über die darunter liegende Protokolle, aber mit vielen verschiedenen Arten von Software, dann breitet sich das aus.
Ich glaube, auch gute Lösungen werden sich rumsprechen. Und diese Sache mit den Identitäten und Namen. Also jetzt hier Facebook und Realnamenszwang, da gibt es ja auch genug Leute und Freunde, die wir da haben können, die einfach mal einen ausgedachten Namen haben. Und wo ich mich dann frage, huch, wer ist denn das? Aber meistens, bei Facebook kommt man immer sehen, wo hat man gemeinsame Freunde? Kann man die fragen, wer ist das? Oder kommt eine Nachricht mit? Also alle Leute, mit denen ich persönlich bekannt bin, sind mir ja persönlich bekannt. Das heißt, die können auch Pseudonym oder so mir gegenüber auftreten, so lange sie Bescheid geben, wie auch immer. Natürlich sind sie da mit mir verbunden. Das ist dann eine ganz andere Ebene.
Aber da kommt jetzt gerade ein ziemlich spannender Aspekt rein. Freunde von Freunden sind ja eigentlich deine Freunde. Also weil du die im Zweifelsfall irgendwo schon mal gesehen hast, oder vielleicht sogar noch gar nicht gesehen hast, aber bald irgendwann sehen wirst. Wie funktioniert das bei verteilten Netzen? Bei einem zentralen Netzwerk ist das klar. Leute, die Leute kennen, die du kennst, sind dann im Zweifelsfall auch schon deine Freunde. Wie ist es bei einer eigentlich gesicherten Datenbasis, wenn ich eigentlich diese Daten ja gar nicht verfügbar hab, auf meinem Port, auf meinem Diaspora Installations Server?
Die Frage ist ja, was synchronisiert wird von den Profilen. Ich hab ja sozusagen einen Server, der entweder bei mir selber läuft oder wo ich einen Account hab. Da ist ein Profil und das gebe ich frei. Da kann ich ja selbst entscheiden, was ich da wem gegenüber freigeben will. Ganz öffentlich, nur für bestimmte Leute. Und die Information, ob ich mit dir befreundet bin. Ich finde, da hast du auch was mitzureden, so wie wir mit dir umgehen. Und da kann man dann auch gemeinsam sicherlich einen Wert finden, wo sagt, das ist dann von dem Server aus bestimmten Leuten verfügbar, diese Informationen oder nicht. Also da ist die Frage, wie macht es Diaspora gerade, finde ich jetzt angebracht, weil wir jetzt hier in der Stelle diskutieren sollten, wie es aussehen sollte.
Und die Definition einer Beziehung sollte natürlich von beiden Teilnehmern beeinflusst werden können. Die Frage ist natürlich, wenn ich jede einzelne Freundschaftsbeziehung einmal anfassen muss, damit ich sagen kann, ja, die gibt es noch. Und ja, die möchte ich gerne weitertragen. Und dann muss ich die eigentlich ein Jahr später, spätestens eigentlich auch nochmal anfassen, weil vielleicht haben wir uns schon lange nicht mehr gesehen und den lade ich vielleicht noch mal zu meiner Hochzeit an, wenn ich überhaupt eine habe. Aber so abends weggehen mache ich mit dem nicht mehr. Das heißt, diese sozialen Netzwerke, die ich abbilde, die verändern sich ja auch. Wenn wir das implizit gestalten, bei Facebook ist es eine Implikation. Im Endeffekt eine Beziehung ist da oder ist nicht da. Und wenn sie nicht da ist, dann ist das klar. Und wenn sie da ist, ist es auch klar. Bei Diaspora kann ich da eine relativ feine Körnung. Ich kann eben bei Facebook, da hast du ja auch eingeführt, die sozialen Kreise, denen ich eigene Granularitäten geben kann. Das erhöht aber die Kosten. Also das erhöht sozusagen den Zeitaufwand, den ein User investieren muss, um sein Netzwerk, seine sozialen gesellschaftlichen Verbindungen abzubilden.
In der Tat, da werden sich Standardwerte etablieren, was üblich ist. Aber der Nutzer kann entscheiden. Dann muss man ein bisschen beobachten, was ist. Irgendwann muss man den Standardwert einstellen, wenn man den System hinstellt oder eine gewisse Auswahl entfragt. Sollte man ihn vorher als Konfrontation geben, dass sie darüber nachdenken und das einmal generell einstellen.
Das ist also die spannende Frage, wie es in diesen neuen sozialen Netzwerken funktionieren kann, dass die Verbindungen zwischen Menschen abgebildet werden. Ich bin gerade ein bisschen überrascht, weil ich dachte, das ist alles gar kein Problem. Es ist nur eine andere Weise der Datenübertragung. Das muss ich gleich nochmal genau nachfragen. Vorher passiert aber folgendes.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Die große Nummer machen wir eigentlich nur am Anfang. Wer hat denn da schon wieder nicht aufgepasst? Muss wohl der Moderator gewesen sein.
War das nicht der Monatanfang?
Irgendwas ist immer Chaosradio, das hört man auch. Heute zu Gast Wetterfrosch. Wie war das? Technisches Gefälle läuft so. Wetterfrosch. Jan Schallerböck und Jennya.
Jan macht juristisches.
Jan hat es schon mal erklärt. Jennya, in einem Satz, was sind Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke?
Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke sind technische Lösungen zur Abbildung von Verbindungen zwischen Entitäten.
Was ist der Unterschied zu zentralen sozialen Netzwerken?
Es gibt nicht eine einzelne Person oder eine einzelne Institution, die darüber die Hoheit hat.
Sondern mehrere und das ist genau das, worüber wir sprechen. Und Jennya hat gerade ein paar Nachfragen gestellt in Hinsicht von, ja bei Facebook sieht das alles ziemlich einfach. Ich hab da Freunde und die haben auch Freunde und Facebook zeigt mir an, ja wenn sie diese Person können, wollen sie auch diese Person kaufen, Freundschaften. Und es ging jetzt darum, wie das in dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken funktioniert. Ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen überrascht, weil ich bin blauurgig davon ausgegangen, dass dezentrale soziales Netzwerk funktioniert im Prinzip genauso wie Facebook, nur dass die Datenkommunikation halt anders ist. Aber von der Oberfläche her ist es eigentlich dasselbe, dachte ich.
Na klar, das ist es auch. Wir haben jetzt ja die Möglichkeit, die Netze zu definieren oder die Protokolle dafür, uns zu überlegen, was alles definierbar ist für den Nutzer und auch einfach auch die Fragen zu beantworten, die Facebook für uns vorher beantwortet hat. Also da, wo man dann bei Facebook immer irgendwie in eine Bettstellerposition kommen musste, zu sagen, ach, ich würde aber gerne so mit meinen Datenschutzeinstellungen umgehen können, das kann man ja an der Stelle, jetzt wenn wir so ein Protokoll entwickeln wollen, noch alles diskutieren.
Das heißt, da wäre dann der Punkt wahrscheinlich, dass die Einstellungen ein bisschen restriktiver wären. Also die Standard-Einstellungen in einem dezentralen sozialen Netzwerk wäre dann wahrscheinlich nicht zeigegeben alles.
Ja, also das ist ja das, was hoch häufig gerade an Facebook kritisiert wird, dass da die Standard-Einstellungen doch sehr prominent und öffentlich sind mitunter. Und da ist ja auch eine Forderung von Datenschutzbeauftragten, den Nutzer halt irgendwie das zulassen zu müssen durch so ein Frage-Antwort-Spiel.
Könnte man das sozusagen auch so machen, dass man, wenn es ja verschiedene Knoten gibt, die es dann in diesem Dezentralen Sozialen Netzwerk gibt, dass man sagt, ich suche mir jetzt einen Knoten aus, der sozusagen einfach so Standard-Einstellungen hat, die mir passen. Also könnte man die von Knoten zu Knoten verändern?
Na klar, da kann sozusagen der Knotenbetreiber auch sagen, ich habe wohl jetzt eher so eine Zielgruppe von Menschen, mache ich das mal so und so.
Kommen Sie auf den Alles-Open-Server, der Schlagname wäre dann Facebook-Knoten, der sich dann für solche Dinge zusitzt. Janja, du hast jetzt sagen gefragt, dass es dann aufwendiger ist für Leute, um darüber Bekanntschaften zu knüpfen. Ist das sozusagen die Sorge, die du da hast? Dass es nicht mehr so einfach ist, neue Leute kennenzulernen oder alte Leute zu finden?
Der Grund, warum Facebook sich so schnell und so erfolgreich verbreitet hat, war, dass die zeitlichen Kosten der Dateien am extrem gering waren. Es war sehr, sehr einfach zu nutzen. Und es war sehr, sehr einfach, weitere Kontakte hinzuzufügen, hinzupflegen, neu zu finden. Und das war ganz bewusst so gestaltet, weil erst durch die Verbindung, durch die Netzwerkeffekte, die einen sehr hohen Wert haben in der Nutzung, funktioniert so ein Netz. Also jetzt nochmal ein Beispiel. Die Daten leben ja irgendwo in diesem Netzwerk. Also ich schreibe, heute habe ich eine Gurke gegessen. Dann schreibt Wetterfrosch, er hat eine Gurke gegessen. Und dann schreiben wir beide, wir haben echt Bauchweh. Daraus, aus dieser Verknüpfung aus der Konstellation, kann man ja schon Mehrwert generieren. Vielleicht haben wir ja bei Pricewaterhouse in Frankfurt am Main gegessen. Vielleicht kennen wir da also jemanden. Also die Information lässt sich erst einmal nutzen, technisch erfassen und weiterverwenden. Das funktioniert aber nur, wenn die Information zuallererst verfügbar ist. Wenn ich alles schließe, wenn ich alles sozusagen sehr sicher gestalte, die Vorstellung ist, niemand darf irgendwas sehen, dann ist diese Information nicht da. Und der Mehrwert entsteht auch gar nicht.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht ein Problem mit dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken. Das ist ja tatsächlich einfach ein Datenschutzeinstellungsproblem. Also selbst ein zentrales Netzwerk wie Facebook würde ja auch sagen, genau das nicht leisten, wenn nur einfach die Datenschutzeinstellungen restriktiver werden.
Völlig richtig. Aber Facebook hat das ja am Anfang auch eben nicht gemacht. Diese Funktionen, diese datenschutzrelevanten Funktionen sind ja erst später hinzugekommen. Also am Anfang war das deutlich öffentlicher. Auch das Bewusstsein. Es ist ja ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Wenn wir darüber reden, wie schaffen wir es, ein dezentrales Netzwerk zum Erfolg zu verhelfen? Wie schaffen wir es, das zu etablieren? Dann müssen wir uns auch fragen, wie kriegen wir es tatsächlich raus? Und es reicht eben nicht, dass jeder das auf seinem Computer in der Küche laufen ist.
Na klar, aber bei Diaspora war jetzt die Standardeinstellung nicht, dass ich sehen konnte, wer alles deine Freunde sind. Wäre jetzt diese Standardeinstellung so gewesen, dass das der Fall wäre, dann hätte es diesen Effekt eher gegeben. Das ist jetzt eine Abwägung, wo man sagt, das war jetzt deswegen nicht so erfolgreich und so losgegangen womöglich. Aber auch gleichzeitig hat es diese Daten eben nicht preisgegeben, was ja auch ein schöner Vorteil ist. Und das ist halt eine Sache, die man abwägen muss. Aber wir hatten vorher E-Mail, wir haben jetzt alle da Facebook oder doch ein großer Teil. Und wenn es jetzt sozusagen eine wirklich gute Empfehlung gibt, wie Diaspora, dann wird sich das auch irgendwie rumsprechen. Man wird irgendwie, also ich hab in meinem Facebook-Profil, meine letzte Erinnerung war jetzt hier, das ist übrigens meine Diaspora-Adresse. Aber ich noch auf einen ganz anderen Punkt kommen, der so ein bisschen fehlte, wo man einfach den Nutzer jetzt abholen muss, um so in diese Richtung auch zu kommen. Und das ist eben das, was Jan auch mit Login meinte. Man baut geschlossene Systeme, wenn man Leute über diese bequemen Sachen erreichen will, dann müssen sie alle Teil dieses Systems werden. Aber das ist ja eben der Punkt, der mich davon auch abhält, Leute in anderen Systemen wie MySpace, Twitter oder so eine Nachricht zu schicken. Da gibt es dann schon erste API-Elemente, die sozusagen bilateral zwischen den beiden Services eine Anbindung erlauben, häufig. Aber eben genau das ist das, was eben gepusht werden muss und das, was letztlich so ein protokollgetriebenes, dezentrales Netzwerk liefern würde. Dass es eben größere Netzwerkaggregate gibt. Wir haben ja, wie gesagt, gmx oder web.de, ein deutschsprachiger Netzwerk, der E-Mail-Anbieter und genauso gibt es natürlich dann weiterhin ein Facebook, wo Leute hinrennen und dann eben Teil von einem wirklichen sozialen Netzwerk sind, was auch dem Netzwerk folgt. Und nicht, das war ja immer so das Bild, wir haben ein Netzwerk, das ist jetzt bei einem Anbieter und ist von der Struktur her gar nicht sozusagen dem technisch, dem sozialen Netzwerk nachempfunden.
Aber das, was Jenga gesagt hat, sind ja eigentlich zwei total wichtige Fragen in dem ganzen Komplex. Die eine Frage ist ja die, und so versuche ich Technik immer ein bisschen zu verstehen, dass ich mir angucke, was für gesellschaftliche Mechanismen stecken da eigentlich dahinter? Was muss das abbilden? Und wo geht es vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus? Entwickelt neue Kulturen? In dem Fall geht es darum, unser Gesellschaftsverhalten abzubilden, unsere Interaktion. Und wenn ich mich in einem bestimmten Umfeld bewege, wenn ich mich aufhalte mit drei Kumpels, dann verhalte ich mich anders, als wenn ich irgendwo auf der Bühne stehe. Das ist ja völlig klar. Und dieses Feeling dafür, ob wir gerade auf der Bühne stehen im Netz oder ob wir gerade mit drei Kumpels reden, das muss sich halt auch in der Software widerspiegeln. Und im Moment geht das manchmal ganz schön drastisch schief. Und das wird sich langsam entwickeln. Und dabei gibt es auch richtig interessante kulturelle Veränderungen. Und eine kann sein, dass man viel offener wird, dass man viel mehr rausbläst. Im negativen Sinn gesprochen, oder dass man einfach toleranter wird im Umgang. Und ich glaube, beides findet statt. Ich glaube, dass es nicht so einfach geht, wie viele das sagen im Sinne von der transparenten Gesellschaft. Und jetzt ist alles von uns immer total transparent. Sondern wir differenzieren natürlich nach unseren Adressatenkreisen. Und das werden wir immer tun. Und die Frage ist, wie kriegen wir es jetzt hin, das so zu strukturieren, dass quasi die technischen Systeme und wir in der Form interagieren, wo beiden Seiten klar ist, was wir eigentlich wollen.
Es gibt ja ein Dezentrale Soziales Netzwerk, was sich auch etabliert hat in den letzten zehn Jahren. Das ist ein Chatprotokoll namens Jabba. Da steht es sozusagen alternativ zu so was wie ICQ oder MSN. Hat mal so seine Seitenleiste mit ganz vielen Benutzern. Und da kann man sich auch aussuchen, nicht nur welchen Kleint man benutzt, sondern auch an welchen Server man sich seinen Account holt. Ein Teil seiner Adresse wird dieser Servername. Und da hast du, Markus, auf der Herfahrt gesagt, wir sind ja alle bei den CCC-Servern. Es ist ja auch interessant, dass dann sozusagen an so einem Punkt viele Leute ein Vertrauen in die bösen Hacker stellen. Weil wir halt an der Stelle dann doch eher den Datentrots natürlich auch bieten wollen. Und es sind halt auch bei uns, also ich bin nicht vom CCC, sondern beim Berliner CCC hab ich meinen Account. Und so hab ich ja auch wieder so einen kleinen soziotopischen Raum. Und ich wette, in Frankreich sind das irgendwie andere Server, die benutzt werden und die sind nicht so stark auf dem CCC. Und so gibt's auch, wenn auch kleine andere Gruppen in deutschsprachigem Bereich, die anderes nutzen. Das macht ja auch Sinn. Ich hab natürlich mit Leuten aus Berlin, aus dem Chaos Computer Club, mehr Kontakt und mehr Nachrichten. Deswegen macht es ja auch sozusagen fast schon ökologisch, ökonomisch Sinn, die Nachrichten auch über einen Server in Berlin zu belassen. Und dann gibt es natürlich zwischen dem Berliner CCC Server wahrscheinlich viel Traffic mit dem Bundes CCC Server, weil Hacker untereinander auch wahrscheinlich bundesweit viel quatschen werden.
Was? Sie reden miteinander?
Und so folgt dann sozusagen auch dieses Entstehen von Servern und Nutzen von Servern den sozialen Kreisen.
Aber das ist ja sozusagen, das ist ja direkt ein Schritt weg von dieser jeder hat sein eigenes Ding in der Küche. Das würde ich ja gerade sagen.
Das wäre jetzt diese vielen zentralen Punkte. Und klar, man muss das weiter und feiner aufliegen, man darf sich damit nicht zufriedengeben. Also 8.000 Leute ist schon viel zu viel. Ab 10.000 muss man Vorreste anspeichern.
Und das ist ja genau, der Job ist ja so ein Ding, das gibt es schon wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich lange. Aber da hat das bei dieser irgendwie, wir stecken, wir tun uns was in einen kleinen Stecker, so in eine Steckdose und dann läuft es, hat auch noch nicht funktioniert. Woran liegt das da? Und vor allen Dingen, wenn das da schon nicht klappt, bei so einem jahrealten Protokoll, wie soll das dann bei so einem komplexen Ding wie einem sozialen Netzwerk funktionieren? Wer soll das denn machen?
Ich glaube, die Sache ist einfach, dass es aus dem Auge gelassen wurde und so ein bisschen wie dieses, warum verschicken wir nicht verschlüsselt E-Mails, weil es ein bisschen kompliziert ist. Und alles ging halt alles, eine Entwicklung lange Zeit zu anderen Formen von, wie Webseiten funktionieren. Und auch solche Unarten, wie dass man E-Mails in einem Webbrowser liest. Und wir haben da viel versäumt, was man eigentlich gerade biegen muss. Und die Frage ist, ob es zu spät ist. Und ich glaube, das glaube ich nie.
Das ist so ein bisschen eine Frage der Marktmodelle, was setzt sich durch und was für Angebote sind. Und da sind ein paar kritische Faktoren, die ändern sich gerade. Erstens, Software wird viel daukompatibler. Man will es nicht glauben.
Das stimmt, das sieht man an Facebook zum Beispiel sehr.
Aber es gibt viel mehr Leute, die Computer benutzen, wo man sagen würde, das hätten die vor 20 Jahren nicht gemacht. Das liegt nicht daran, dass die so viel computeraffiner geworden sind, sondern dass einfach viel mehr Produkte da sind, die die auch benutzen können. Und so ist das denkbar, dass das auch für einen einfachen Server, für ein dezentrales soziales Netzwerk geht. Das ist ein. Und das andere ist, die Hardwarekosten gehen. Und das, was dafür nötig ist an Hardware, das passt zusammen. Wenn du sagst, so ein Server kostet nur noch 25 Euro oder 17 Euro oder sowas, und da ist die Software gleich mit drauf und den steckst du in die Steckdose. Nicht mehr 1000 Euro oder 5000 Euro, dann ist das irgendwie ein anderes Angebot.
Aber wann ist es denn so weit, dass es wirklich klappt? Das ist ja die Frage. Wann gibt's denn zum Beispiel, warum bastelt es niemand mal so einen Jabber-Server in diesem Steckdosen-Computer? Das müsste doch einfach so ein komisches dezentrales Netzwerk. Hier, wetterfrosch. Technischer Kompetenzberg, ganz oben.
Also ein Problem, das wir immer noch haben, ist, dass wir kein richtiges Internet zu Hause haben. Also feste IP-Adressen wären schon sehr praktisch, aber na klar, man kann auch da Lösungen finden, die mit den dynamischen Adressen, die sie vergeben werden, klarkommen. Es ist eine Sache von, müsste man einfach mal machen.
Aber das wird ja jetzt mit der IPv6-Umstellung alles viel besser.
Oh ja.
Das ist sozusagen das Highland der Technik. Die Frage ist ja auch, also Jabber zum Beispiel funktioniert ja auch intern bei Firmen. Es sind ja sozusagen Firmenetze, die einen eigenen E-Mail-Server haben, die auch einen eigenen Jabber-Server haben. Und da ist zum Beispiel Datenschutz ganz, ganz wichtig, weil die sagen, wenn wir irgendwas über einen externen Dienst laufen lassen, dann können wir nicht mehr garantieren, dass die Information unser Haus nicht verlässt. Und insofern, das können ja auch Einfallstore sein. War es ja auch für E-Mail. Also E-Mail haben die Leute ja zuerst auf der Arbeit verwendet und haben dann irgendwann gemerkt, hey cool, das funktioniert auch privat. Da kann ich mich auch auf ein Bier verabreden. Aber die Einführungen, auch Universitäten, sind ja dann in dem Fall Arbeitsplätze.
Und dann hat irgendjemand angefangen, PowerPoint-Präsentationen per E-Mail zu verschicken. Und das war der Anfang vom Ende.
Genau. Und wenn wir jetzt also sagen, wir nutzen oder wir vergleichen E-Mail und soziale Netzwerke, könnte man ja auch hingehen und sagen, Diaspora gehört in jedes eigentliche Unternehmensnetzwerk. Eigentlich überall, wo ein Fileserver steht, überall, wo ein E-Mail funktioniert, sollte auch ein eigener Diaspora-Note stehen, weil die Informationen, die man mit seinen Arbeitskollegen teilt, die man seinem Arbeitgeber mitteilen möchte, ist nicht zwangsläufig dieselbe Information, die man seinen Freunden mitteilen möchte.
Da bin ich jetzt aber ein bisschen überrascht, weil dann sagst du ja im Prinzip, dass man zwei soziale Netzwerkprofile in Zukunft betreiben müsste. Nämlich eins nur auf der Arbeit benutzt, dann auch auf dem Knoten auf der Arbeit ist und dann noch eins draußen. Das ist ja genau das, was man nicht will bei einem sozialen Netzwerk.
Ja, habt ihr das kürzlich in den Nachrichten? Daimler-Kollegen wurden zu ihrem Chef beordert, weil sie eine Gruppe geliked haben, wo also der Chef von Daimler irgendwie nicht so gut wegkam.
Wieso hat er ein Tequilla-Trinkspül mitgemacht?
Nee, da wurde so ein bisschen kritisiert und das haben die Leute einfach geliked. Das fanden die gut, dass der mal so sein Fett wegbekommt. Dann wurden sie eben zum Chef zitiert und ihnen wurde nochmal gezeigt, was sie eigentlich unterschrieben haben bei der Einstellung. Das war nämlich, dass man das Unternehmen natürlich auch im Privaten so nicht beleidigt und irgendwie respektvoll behandelt. Das ist sozusagen aus der Unternehmenssicht irgendwie auch klar und verständlich, aber die Frage ist eben, wie kommt es Unternehmen dazu, die privaten Nachrichten oder die privaten Aktionen von Mitarbeitern oder von Leuten zu lesen. Und das tut es nur deswegen, weil ja eben alle auf diesem Facebook sind. Und das ist ein Problem, was wir über dezentrale Netze ja durchaus lösen können.
Wobei da natürlich auch der Faktor ist, ich hab auch gerne zwei E-Mail-Adressen, weil Sachen in der Firma haben vielleicht firmengeheim relevante Inhalte, wo ich dann sag, da ist dann auch bitte der Administrator unserer Firma am Mailserver, für gerade stehen, dass diese Mails sicher liegen. Und dann möchte ich dieses Problem sozusagen nicht so fahrlässig sein, dass irgendein Anbieter in die Hand zu drücken oder das Problem Kumpel aufzubürden, dass der dann auch noch für das Geschäftsgeheimnis meiner Firma gerade stehen soll. Und insofern ist das mehrere Accounts haben durchaus mal sinnvoll. Die Frage ist, wie man das dann verknüpft und wie das sich im Verkleiden des Nutzers darstellt.
Das ist ja ein herer Ansatz, so was zu sagen. Aber ich glaube, die meisten Nutzer wollen ja genau Folgendes. Sie wollen irgendwie eigentlich einen Netzwerke-Account haben, mit dem sie auch mit den Arbeitskollegen Freunde sind, wo sie aber eigentlich die Möglichkeit haben zu sagen, folgende Information möchte ich nicht, dass sie meinen Chef zum Beispiel erreicht. Also kann man sagen, eine selber Schuld, wenn euch nicht klar ist, dass eure Facebook-Likes euren Chef bereichnen, dann hättet ihr euch mal die Datenschutzeinstellungen angucken müssen. Das ist ja, glaube ich, eher tatsächlich ein User-Problem als ein Problem eines dezentralen oder zentralen Netzwerks.
Na ja, in erster Linie ist es ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Teilweise ist es ja so, ich kenne jetzt eine Branche, die eher mit Kommunikation zu tun hat. Dort ist es so, wenn du in eine Firma reinkommst, hast du eigentlich am dritten Tag sämtliche Mitarbeiter, die du einmal auf dem Flur auf dem Kaffee gesehen hast, schon als Freunde anfragen bei Facebook. Das ist nicht schlecht, das ist gut, weil da funktioniert der ganze Flurfunk das, was normalerweise früher, als man noch geraucht hat, hat man das ja eben bei der Raucherpause noch besprochen, was jetzt sozusagen gerade anliegt oder wie man irgendwie jetzt mit dem Kunden Sachen bespricht. Das funktioniert ja so nicht mehr. Da gibt es dann im Zweifel einen Facebook-Chat.
Wir halten also fest, Nichtraucher, die keinen Facebook-Account haben, sind Raues.
Naja, es ist ja so, wir sind ja Menschen, wir sind ja adaptiv. Also wir suchen uns ja immer den Weg, der am einfachsten ist, der am wenigsten kostet, der am schnellsten funktioniert und der am schnellsten eben auch zum Ergebnis führt. Und darin sind wir extrem gut, sonst wären wir nicht so weit gekommen. Sonst würden wir jetzt nicht hier über dezentrale soziale Netzwerke sprechen.
Du meinst, wir haben eigentlich Luxusprobleme?
Wir haben absolut Luxusprobleme.
Was wir jetzt diskutieren, sind ja zum großen Teil soziale Komponenten, die ganz viel auch damit zu tun haben, dass Leute, die das Zeug benutzen, sich darüber Gedanken machen müssen. Und das ist ja glaube ich, wenn ich manche Leute betrachte, der eigentliche Fallstrick. Das ist ja sowohl bei Facebook als auch bei den dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken so. Die Leute müssen sich selber Gedanken machen, damit es so besser im Sinne eines Datenschutzideals wird. Glaubt ihr wirklich, das ist Erfolgversprechend?
Ich glaube der Trick ist, dass es implizit ist. Dass er dann, so wie Wetter gerade sagte, vielleicht anfängt es tatsächlich absichtlich auf der Arbeit, mit einer anderen E-Mail-Adresse unterwegs zu sein als privat. Das machen viele von uns sowieso. Oder sogar noch mehr E-Mail-Adressen für verschiedene Kontexte. Und in unterschiedlichen Applikationen weiß ich wieder, habe ich einen anderen Kontext. Wir erlauben zum Beispiel und empfehlen das auch allen, wir erlauben die private Nutzung von E-Mail am Arbeitsplatz. Viele Firmen machen das nicht. Aber Bedingung ist bei uns, dass für die E-Mail-Nutzung ein Web-Interface benutzt wird, sodass sich das deutlich optisch abhebt von dem internen Interface. Das ist ein einfacher Trick. Aber es passiert wahnsinnig viel seltener, dass es so eine Vermischung gibt dieser zwei Sphären, die man halt aus vielen Gründen im Moment ganz schön trennen muss und wo es aber sowieso auch sinnvoll ist sie zu trennen. Aber es ist nicht einfach.
Dann müsste man quasi ein dezentrales Firmen mit hässlichem Design und super effektiv und dann noch ein dezentrales Netzwerk in clicky-bunty machen.
Ich glaube es sind unterschiedliche Applikationen, die sozusagen die Kernapplikation des jeweiligen Netzwerks ist. Für deinen Austausch mit deiner Mama ist es vielleicht im Moment das Medium-E-Mail, weil das funktioniert und das läuft. Und für jemand anderes ist es für eine andere Peer Group ist es halt auch eine andere Applikation. Für mich ist es Twitter in einem bestimmten Kontext und auf der Arbeit wird es vielleicht ein Tool sein, wie euer Intranet. Und da habt ihr einen eigenen Java-Service, der da integriert ist.
Ich muss aber tatsächlich sagen, es gibt ganz, ganz viele Leute, die nutzen einfach Facebook. Also für alles. Da rede ich jetzt sowohl von Kollegen, als auch von Privatpersonen, die ich kenne. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das ein erfolgsversprechender Ansatz aus User Perspektive ist, dass man sagt, pass mal auf, hier ein neues System und du musst aussehen, mach zweifelchen in der Applikation. Ich glaube tatsächlich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Werden wir sehen.
Werden wir sehen. Okay. Ihr könnt auch gerne anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. Wenn ihr auch denkt, das ist doch alles Quatsch, was die da erzählen oder der eine oder der andere, könnt ihr gerne hier Bescheid sagen. Die Nummer kennt ihr ja. Jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit über die sozialen Komponenten besprochen. Das hört sich dann so ein bisschen an. Die technischen Herausforderungen sind eigentlich schon gemeistert. Ist das tatsächlich der Fall? Also es ist eigentlich nur eine Frage von, es muss jetzt mal fertig werden, dann geht es los. Oder gibt es tatsächlich noch ein paar Probleme, die da geklärt werden müssen, bevor das irgendwie funktioniert?
Ah, so. Gut, dass ich jetzt schon gefragt habe. Ja, man muss es immer nur machen. So, mein Gott, alles ist möglich. Es ist halt eine Menge Arbeit. Und wenn man es richtig machen will, muss man noch viele andere Probleme auch dabei lösen. Was weiß ich, die Verwendung der Programmiersprachen und so, da fängt es schon an. Und da ist halt wirklich auch die Frage, auf welcher Ebene wollen wir jetzt, also das sind jetzt Manöverfragen, die man eigentlich diskutieren muss, auf welcher Ebene geht es weiter sozusagen sollen? Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Also wenn ihr an dieser Diskussion Dezentrale Netzwerke noch einen ganz bestimmten Punkt geklärt haben wollt, dann ist auch jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt nun anzurufen, weil ich kann versprechen, wir werden in 40 Minuten nicht mehr den Rest der Welt erklären. Das wird wohl nicht klappen. Und deswegen ist jetzt nochmal eine gute Idee. Mangels Hörer, sagen würde ich jetzt nicht mehr wissen, was ist denn das große technische Problem? Also zum Beispiel, was ich mir vorstelle, ist, die Kommunikation zwischen diesen einzelnen Knoten, wie wird die denn gestaltet, ist das schon klar, wie das laufen soll? Wird dann einfach Jabber benutzt? Also können diese Knoten jabbern oder was passiert da?
Also Schatz, sollten wir nochmal einen kleinen Überblick geben, auch mit der Hilfe von Jan, welche verschiedene Ansätze es noch so gibt. Letztlich sind das glaube ich bei Diaspora Web Server, die miteinander interagieren und sich Daten über Web Server, HTTP-Protokolle übergeben, die dabei verschlüsselt sind. Es gibt andere Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerksansätze, wo tatsächlich das Jabber zugrunde liegende Protokoll XMPP verwendet wird. Das geht sogar so weit, dass du mit deinem Google-Email-Account und sogar mit deinem Facebook-Account Jabber nutzen kannst. Das ist gleichzeitig im Jabber-Protokoll kannst du Leute, also ich hab jetzt hier das Jabber, das tolle alternative Ding, und Facebook hat sich sozusagen auch ein bisschen den Jabber-Server angeklebt. Das heißt, ich kann über meinen Jabber-Align mit Leuten chatten, die in der Web-Oberfläche von Facebook sind. Also bei mir hat das immer geklappt, als ich das probiert hab. Meine Facebook-Freunde sind halt so meine Hauptzielgruppe mit den Leuten, mit denen ich chatte.
Es klappt tatsächlich manchmal, aber es ist nicht so ein Ding, was man sozusagen, also wenn man sich anfängt darauf zu verlassen, funktioniert es meistens nicht. Dann sagt man so eine Sätze, aber ich war heute die ganze Zeit online. Das sind dann sozusagen Standardprogramme. Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, ob es funktioniert. Aber trotzdem nochmal die Frage, das hätte ich technisch geklärt. Also ich sag nur eine Frage, der Programmierer eines Dezentralen Sozialen Netzwerkes entscheidet sich einfach, er macht jetzt was und damit sind alle Probleme weg.
Nee, es fehlt die Spezifikation. Man muss sich darüber einigen, was man benutzt. Zum einen muss man sich auf einem Anwendungslayer Gedanken machen. Wie sehen die Features genau aus? Welche Einstellungen sollen möglich sein? Da wird Facebook am ehesten auch das Vorbild sein, denke ich mal. Weil Facebook, die machen sowas in der Perfektion, mit dem Funktionalitätenumfang als erste, als Pioniere, das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen die Blaupause, oder als erfolgreichste derzeit. Ich mein, Myspace war sicher auch vorher da, Twitter ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen eine andere Anwendung. Aktuell ist es halt Facebook, deswegen klar, das wird dann irgendwie ein bisschen die Blaupause sein, von dem wie es von der Anwendung her funktioniert. Und da muss man sich ja technisch überlegen und fix machen. Das sind halt auch Glaubenskriege, die zwischen Technikern ausgeführt werden, jetzt welches Software die bessere ist und welche Programmiersprache man daneben muss. Und gerade wenn wir jetzt mit so heeren Ansprüchen rangehen, dass das auf kleinen Computern effizient laufen soll, auf 100 Dollar Laptops in der dritten Welt, dann muss man sich da ordentlich, ausgiebig Gedanken machen und eigentlich auch Kohle reinstecken, eine Menge. Und dann sind irgendwie die 200.000 auch schnell weg, die sie erst Berührungs hatten.
Da sind aber auch viele Leute mittlerweile dran, ne? Also das W3C, die haben ja den Standard hinter...
Genau, die Internet-Standard-Organisation, oder zumindest was das WWW anbelangt.
Alle, die sind irgendwie, würde ich sagen, neben der ITF. Aber es gibt auch noch eine ganze Reihe von weiteren. Die machen dazu seit zwei, drei Jahren schon intensive Arbeitsgruppenarbeit. Und machen dazu Konferenzen. Eine findet in Berlin demnächst statt und diskutieren das weit über Diaspora hinaus.
Dass Diaspora jetzt gerade zu sagen, der erste Schuss, der am erfolgreichsten war. status.net, kannst du das nochmal kurz erklären, wie das funktioniert?
Das ist im Prinzip aber ein sehr ähnlicher Ansatz, der auch nur Statusmeldungen versucht auszutauschen. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe, die darunter liegenden Protokolle sind nicht so wahnsinnig unterschiedlich. Es ist aber doch eine ganze Bandbreite, die ineinander verzahnt werden. Web-ID, teilweise kommt OpenID und OAuth als Mechanismen zum Einsatz in dem ganzen Setup der Architekturen, die da zusammenspielen. Aber es kommt halt auch sehr drauf an, was man eigentlich für einen Teil von sozialen Netzwerkfunktionalitäten abbilden will.
Und noch viel mehr. Letztlich ist auch eine Frage, wie man die Sache benutzt, die man hat. Ich meine, ich kann euch alle einladen zu einer Party über ein Facebook-Event. Ich kann euch auch eine E-Mail schreiben. Ich kann auch an diese E-Mail eine Veranstaltungsdatei, das gibt es auch, so ein Kalenderstandard, dass ich einfach, da bin ich immer im Kalenderprogramm, ein Outlook oder ein Senderbord, kann ich eine Veranstaltung machen. Schreibe ich was, wo, wann, Beschreibung, hier noch einen Link oder so. Da gibt es einen Standard für ein Dateiformat, wo ich dann in meinem Kalenderprogramm sagen kann, ich speichere mir das als eine Datei. Und dann schicke ich an meinen Leuten per E-Mail eine E-Mail, die gehen an den jeweiligen Server, wo sich die Empfänger für entschieden haben, wo die E-Mail hingehen soll, wo sie halt ihren Account haben. Und dann ist eine Datei dran, können sie draufklicken, sich in ihren Kalenderprogramm laden und haben sie gleich in ihrem Computer, müssen danach noch nicht mal mehr eine Webseite aufrufen, um an diese Information ranzukommen. Und das ist einfach eine Sache, wie nutzen wir die Technik, die wir haben. Das hat jetzt wenige abgerundete Ecken auf dem Weg.
Man kann im Peer-to-Peer-Gedanken ja auch mal weiter spinnen. Ich finde das ja wichtig, dass man auch schaut, dass es ein ganz großer Set von vielen Anwendungsfeldern gibt. Und einer wäre zum Beispiel, wo man sagt, man begreift im Peer-to-Peer-Sinne eben auch Wireless Networking. Die Freifunk-Szene hat das jahrelang vorgemacht, zu sagen, wir versuchen uns untereinander zu vernetzen. Das wäre total super gewesen in Tunesien, in Ägypten und in einigen anderen Ländern in letzter Zeit. Wenn die auf ihren Handys ein Wireless Mesh drauf gehabt hätten, dann hätten die noch einen Uplink gebraucht und im Wesentlichen sich untereinander prima austauschen können. Also man kann das viel breiter noch denken. Und ich glaube auch, dass das gar nicht alles so abwegig ist. Wenn alle in zehn Jahren irgendwelche Android-Handys, Smartphones haben und da ist das halt per Default drin, dann müssen die halt den Revolutionary Mode einschalten.
Gut, wir werden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde darüber reden, ob man das vielleicht tatsächlich jetzt im GmbX mal hinkriegt oder nicht. Vorher gibt es das Frips Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und ich möchte euch doch noch eine kleine Musik präsentieren, denn ich habe heute auf Twitter herumgefragt, wer mal ein bisschen Musik fürs Chaosradio vorschlagen will. Und da ist unter anderem ein wirklich sehr schöner Track bei rumgekommen, Creative Commons Musik auch, kann man sich runterladen, einfach so der 8-Bit-Sound mit einem wirklichen Klassiker verbindet. Ich verrate jetzt erst mal nicht, was es ist, aber ich bin mir.
Dann ist Fritz Info und danach geht's hier weiter.
14 Informationen zum Datenverkehr.
Wegen des Kabelbrandes am Ostkreuz waren nicht nur Funknetze, sondern auch einzelne Rechenzentren in Berlin zeitweilig nicht erreichbar. So fielen nicht nur Internetseiten der Deutschen Bahn, sondern etwa auch der Grünen Partei aus. Infrastruktur der Piratenpartei lahmgelegt. Letzte Woche baten französische Behörden um grenzüberschreitende Ermittlungshilfe. Die deutsche Staatsanwaltschaft und die Polizei Offenbach schalteten deshalb vorübergehend die Internetpräsenz der Piratenpartei ab. Grund für den Schritt war ein freiliegender Bitterhaufen des französischen Energiekonzerns EDF in einer offenen Datenablage der Piraten. In Deauville wird Internetpolitik gemacht. Die Chefs der G8-Staaten drängen auf Maßnahmen, um Kinder vor Online-Straftätern zu schützen. Außerdem sollen Urheberrechtsverletzungen verhindert werden. Der französische Präsident Nicolas Sarkozy will Grundregeln fürs Internet. Bitte fahren Sie hier besonders vorsichtig.
Wir wünschen allen Datenreisenden eine angenehme Anbindung.
Vielen Dank Philipp Burger. Chaosradio heute im Blue Moon mit Markus Richter und natürlich wieder zahlreichen Gästen, nämlich Jena Jan Schallerböck und Wetterfrau Schallow und herzlich willkommen noch mal zurück. Ein lebendiger Aufmiss das hier und alle waren schon mal dran, nur der Wetterfrau Schallow nicht, der jetzt in zwei Sätzen erklärt, was ist eigentlich ein Dezentrale Soziales Netzwerk, das Ding, über das wir die ganze Zeit sprechen?
Das ist eine Alternative zu Facebook, bei der jeder selbst Teil des Netzes wird.
Und wie macht er das?
Indem er sich eine Software installieren kann, einen Server und selber sozusagen Teil des Facebooks wird und Accounts anlegt oder zumindest sich für einen anderen Anbieter entscheidet, nämlich einen von mehreren, ein soziales Netzwerk, das über eine Auswahl an Anbietern möglich macht.
Das ist ja bis jetzt noch ein relativ abstraktes Konzept, das gibt es noch nicht so wirklich. In einer Ausprägung kann man es versuchen. Diaspora versucht ja sozusagen eine Facebook Alternative, eine Dezentrale zu sein. Es gibt aber etwas, das schon so in die Richtung gegangen ist, nämlich Identica. Das ist ein Twitter-Klon. Also Twitter kennt ja alle 140 Zeichen, Freunde, also wie jemanden folgen, retweeten, replyen. Identica hatte genau diesen dezentralen Ansatz. Das ist sozusagen also ein Open Source. Das Open Source-Ding, da kann sich so ein eigener Server auch machen und es soll auch irgendwie alles untereinander funktionieren und mit Twitter. Und Jena, du beschäftigst dich ja mit diesem ganzen Ding auch so aus der User-Perspektive. Identica ist ein bisschen wie das Artefernsehen. Super Idee, aber keiner guckt's.
Ich hab jetzt gerade mal geschaut, was sagen die Leute jetzt irgendwie gerade aktuell zum Thema irgendwie Twitter versus Identica. Und Identica ist ja schon seit 2008 draußen. Also die haben das gestartet, die haben sich das Twitter angeguckt und Twitter ist ja auch mal gestartet. Also das heißt, kann man immer noch sagen, Anlaufschwierigkeiten hat jeder. Die Frage ist natürlich immer, warum benutzen die Leute das? Also Twitter hätte auch erst dann wirklich funktioniert, als nicht nur die privaten Kommunikationen, die privaten Konversationen zwischen einzelnen Menschen dort waren, sondern als man gemerkt hat, hey, ich kann Wolken von Begriffen mir anschauen. Ich kann sozusagen sehen, in der Real-Time, also in der Echtzeit kann ich mir anschauen, was denken die Leute eigentlich da draußen, was schreiben sie? Und in dieser kann somit eigentlich das machen, was die Meinungsforschungsinstitute vor, in den letzten 50 Jahren vor Wahlen immer gemacht haben. Die haben Leute angerufen und gefragt, was denken sie jetzt eigentlich zur CDU? Das kann ich heute ja irgendwie direkt jederzeit, jeden Tag mir bei Twitter anschauen. Und das ist der Mehrwert, den ich brauche. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich einen alternativen Software habe, die eigentlich dieselbe Funktionalität bietet, aber nicht genug Leute, ist die Frage, warum dorthin gehen? Was hab ich dort, wenn ich dort diese Menge nicht mehr hab und die Qualität auch nicht? Also wenn ich beispielsweise auf Identica eine Gruppe von Atomwissenschaftlern hätte, die sich zu Themen um Fukushima herum unterhalten würde und da debattieren würde, super, großartig, dann wäre das etwas, warum Leute sich tatsächlich damit auseinandersetzen. Also Content is King. Das war schon immer im Internet der Fall. Das bleibt hier auch natürlich in diesem System der Fall. Wenn ich immer nur Leute habe bei Identica, die sagen Hallo, ich bin jetzt auch da, sprecht mit mir, dann ist halt die Timeline nicht ganz so spannend, wie wenn Leute sich gerade irgendwie Fußball angucken und sagen Tor, juhu, endlich.
Ich glaube, dass die da mehr Aufmerksamkeit auf Datenschutz, unabhängig jetzt, wie es realisiert ist, in der Qualität nur gut tun kann. Also man hat nicht so den Effekt, wenn jetzt die Piraten sich alle intern irgendwie über was aufregen, als jetzt bei Nutzergruppe genommen, die jetzt auf Twitter sehr präsent ist, weil es einfach eine technikaffinierte Zielgruppe ist, dann geht halt das Schlagwort nicht sofort ganz hoch, nur weil es so sozusagen überproportional großer Anteil an Nutzer aus dieser Gruppe gibt, wenn die halt sozusagen ein bisschen verdeckter sozusagen ihre Kommunikation machen. Und das wäre ja sozusagen Seiteneffekt, der durch ein Dezentrale Soziales Netzwerk auch auftreten würde. Ich überlege mir, in welchem Kontext poste ich meine Meinung oder meine Nachrichten. Und wenn das halt jetzt irgendwie nicht öffentlich ist, kann ich ja sagen, das sind Dinge, da stehe ich öffentlich zu, die veröffentliche ich in meinen Profilen und die können über alle Knotenpunkte hinweg transferiert werden und man kann von jedem Punkt aus gucken, was du sozusagen gerade wirklich öffentlich gemacht.
Warte mal, ich bin gerade ein bisschen verwirrt. Hatt ich nicht eigentlich die Frage gestellt, warum Identika nicht funktioniert? Da gerade ein ganzes Stück wieder weg davon. Das ist aber genau die spannende Frage, die ich wissen möchte. Weil also noch mal meine kleine Privatsprivatschalistik, wer von euch findet aus Datenschutzgründen oder das Datenschutzperspektive Identika besser als Twitter? Handt ihn mal bitte ein, zwei, drei. So alle sind dafür. Das heißt, es scheint so eine Art Konsens zu sein, Identika ist schon eine coole Idee. Wenn jetzt einfach alle Leute, die Ahnung haben, dahin gegangen wären und gesagt hätten so, Twitter, Mittelfinger hoch, das klappt einfach nicht mehr, dann wäre das ja möglicherweise passiert. Aber es war halt so, die Leute sind zu bequem und gehen da nicht hin. Also woran scheitert das?
Weil es nicht unbedingt immer darum geht, was die Leute machen, die Ahnung haben oder die auch nicht unbedingt immer ihre Ahnung folgen. Es ist ein bisschen die Frage nach dem How do you get them to drink your Kool Aid? Wie es der Dave Recordin, der hinter OpenID steht, mal gesagt hat, mittlerweile arbeitet er bei Facebook. Und die Frage ist salopp übersetzt, wie kriegst du es hin, dass sie deine Brause trinken? Das heißt, wie kriegst du den Effekt hin? Und das sind momentan irre soziale und technische Innovationen, die permanent um uns herum stattfinden. Das ist eine wahnsinnig spannende Zeit eigentlich. Und da passieren dauernd neue Entdeckungen und neue Tools tun sich. Und dann ist das gerade hip und dann ist das. Und was es das nächste sein wird und was das nun spezifisch hip machen wird, das kann ich im Moment nicht sagen. Da gibt es, wie gesagt, zig Visionen und Ideen, wie das aussehen könnte. Und keiner hat bisher das Ding hip gemacht. Es gibt sozusagen nicht die Killer App dafür.
Genau.
Um zurück zu meiner Frage zu kommen, heißt es also, es kann gar nicht passieren, dass ein neuer Dienst gewinnt, wenn er einfach nur dasselbe macht, wie der alte Dienst, aber datenschutzfreundlich.
Also ich glaube auch, dass Identika deswegen nicht so durchgezündet hat, weil es sich eben nur als Alternative auf Twitter versteht. Und das ist natürlich total gut und super, da was zu haben. Das ist ja kein Kritikpunkt. Aber die Leute wollen ja, wie du auch sagst, nur einen Account haben. Und da ist ja schon Twitter und Facebook zu viel.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Da müsste man eigentlich gleich sagen, das ist ein Tool, das auch die Features von Facebook kann.
Alle dezentrale soziale Netzwerke, die ich heute gehört habe, hier werden auch nicht mehr erkennen als Facebook. Da wird auch keiner hingehen, aus genau dem selben Grund.
Ja, aber Facebook ist ja schon Twitter und mehr. Und wenn du halt hingehst und du machst nur eins für Twitter, dann kannst du auch nicht erwarten, dass das...
Nein, das ist klar das Identität. Was ich meine ist, es gibt diese Idee, die abstrakte Idee der dezentralen sozialen Netzwerke. Es gibt aber nichts, was ich bis jetzt, was ich heute hier gehört habe, was das besser könnte als Facebook, also für den normalen User. Von daher ist es doch eigentlich ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen.
Man muss ja sehen, wir haben jetzt gerade den Hund auf den Mund geschossen und schauen jetzt gerade irgendwie, wie lange der mit Sauerstoff überlebt. Also die Technologie ist überhaupt noch nicht so weit, dass wir wirklich verlässliche Zahlen und verlässliche User-Verhaltensrichtungen hatten. Wir hatten vorhin den Fall dieses einen ominösen Netzwerkgründers in Deutschland, der sozusagen Facebook kopiert hat und gesagt hat, ich bin jetzt irgendwie mit Lok in der King und kurze Zeit später ist das Ding jetzt eigentlich ja schon leer, weil keiner will es benutzen. Warum auch? Im Prinzip machen wir diese Erfahrungen gerade täglich neu. Und es ist der Unterschied zwischen Facebook und Twitter ist ja ein ganz, ganz, ganz großer. Bei Facebook kommuniziere ich mit den Leuten, die in meinem sozialen Mikrokosmos sind. Bei Twitter kommuniziere ich mit allen Leuten, die ich noch nie kenne, die ich noch nie gehört habe und mit denen ich noch nie irgendwas zu tun hatte, solange es um ein konkretes Thema geht. Also wenn ich einen Hashtag benutze und Leute, die zu diesem Hashtag etwas sagen, wenn ich mit denen schon mal kommuniziert habe, super. Wenn sie neu dazukommen und sozusagen auf diesen Hashtag in meine Timeline plötzlich aufpoppen, ist das auch super. Das sind ganz andere Kommunikationsmodelle. Deswegen gibt es auch die beiden Netze. Deswegen ist es auch nicht so, dass die Leute sagen, ich mache jetzt nur noch Facebook und ich mache nur noch Twitter. So Identica hat halt in dem Moment nur eine Kopie von Twitter angeboten, die dann auch noch in diversen Sachen begrenzt war. Identica ist vielleicht super für Unternehmen, ist vielleicht super für Mikrogruppen. Wenn man sich darüber unterhält, ob man heute Abend wassergefüllte Luftballons auf eine VIP-Party an der Oberbaumbrücke schmeißen will, dann ist das vielleicht besser, einen geschlossenen Dienst zu nutzen als Twitter. Also aus nachvollziehbaren Erwägungen. Aber für einzelne Fälle ist das vielleicht auch tatsächlich die bessere Lösung. Es wird aber nie diese Masse erreichen, solange es nicht einen USB hat. Also nicht einen Grund, den es besser, schneller und...
Genau, und was kann dieser Grund sozusagen, was kann Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke realistisch vorstellbar für einen Unique Selling Point haben gegenüber Facebook?
Datenschutz und Ausbeisicherheit.
Genau, das ist kein Argument. Ganz ehrlich, für die große Masseleute ist es kein Argument, weil dann wäre Identica vor Twitter.
Ich gebe dir da völlig recht und ich glaube, man kann es schlicht nicht sagen. Das Netz ist voller emergenter Effekte. Es passiert plötzlich irgendwas, das niemand vorher hätte prognostizieren können. Teilweise sind es totale Zufälle und dann ist mal wieder jemand multimilliardär in USA geworden. Und teilweise sind es so Geschichten. Das fand ich ein tolles Beispiel irgendwie, wo du sagst, irgendwie die japanischen Nuklearwissenschaftler. Und plötzlich entwickelt sich da ein Netzwerkeffekt und BOOM! Ist dann irgend ein Ding ganz groß. Das ist vielleicht nicht Diaspora, sondern ein ganz anderes Ding, werden wir sehen. Aber das, was das Incentive ist, das ist ja nicht nur Datenschutz, sondern das ist ja auch eine ganz andere Netzwerkstruktur im Grunde, eine andere Architektur, die schafft andere Möglichkeiten. Und bisher haben sich immer die Architekturen durchgesetzt, die eine höhere Durchlässigkeit haben, weil die Anzahl der Möglichkeiten größer ist.
Was genau meinst du durchlässigkeit?
Das ist, kommen wir zurück zum Beispiel E-Mail. Da ist es ganz klar, das ist nicht in so einem geschlossenen System geblieben, sondern das ist irgendwann da rausgegangen, weil es einfach ein Plus an Möglichkeiten war, wenn du in einem Alternativsystem auch agieren kannst. Dann kann sich Konkurrenz rausbilden. Das sind ganz triviale Geschichten, ja. Also sonst hättest du überhaupt nicht diese Steigerung der Qualität von Web Interfaces bei E-Mail, also in den letzten Jahren erlebt, wenn das immer nur CompuSurf gewesen wäre zum Beispiel.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin skeptisch, ich halte es für eine gute Idee. Ich bin aber tatsächlich skeptisch, ob meine Mutter in irgendwie absehbarer Zeit Diaspora benutzt wird oder irgendwas, was danach oder sich ein Steck an ihre Steckdose steckt.
Aber machen wir das doch genau andersrum. Sagen wir doch mal jetzt ganz konkret, wie schaffen wir es, deine Mutter in dem Moment...
Alter, da hast du was zu meiner Mutter gesagt.
Deine Mutter hat ein Diaspora-Account. Wie schaffen wir es tatsächlich in kurzen, im kleinen Bereich solche Nutzung zu forcieren? Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise einen Fritz-Diaspora-Note hätten, dann hätten sämtliche Hörer dieser Sendung...
Dann hätten wir ein Problem mit dem Rundfunkstaatsänderungsvertrag, weil wir natürlich keine soziale Netzwerke betreiben dürfen.
Aber gut, so wie es früher war, da hat man sich am Marktplatz getroffen. Das war sozusagen die Abbildung der sozialen Netze. Dann gab es irgendwann Fidunet. Das waren sozusagen schwarze Bretter noch per Telefonleitung. Da hat man sich dann mit dem Modem eingewählt und haben sich auch soziale Strukturen etabliert, die dann wiederum den Übergang ins Internet überdauert haben. Die sind dann jetzt inzwischen in den Newsgroups zu finden und schreiben sich Beleidigungen auf einem anderen Protokoll. Die Beleidigungen sind aber dieselben geblieben.
Also diese Attraktivität, dann muss ich denken, wahrscheinlich wird dann das nächste Facebook fortscheinern.
Das Fido-Net war ja schon auf dem Weg dahin, wo das Internet heute steht, ein solcher Zustand, wo halt der Haus-Nerd um die Ecke sozusagen, also da hat einer so ein schwarzes Brett betrieben und andere haben sich darauf eingewählt. Das war schon so eine kleine physisch geschlossene Benutzergruppe, die wiederum an ein Netzwerk angeschlossen war, weil sich eben diese schwarzen Bretter untereinander austauschten und damit auch protokollartig Informationen von dann wieder weiteren Brettern weitergegeben haben.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es ja so, dass man anthropologisch zurückschaut und sieht, dass die Dinosaurier nicht überlebt haben. Und die Fidunet-Betreiber ja auch wirklich, ja die muss man suchen. Die findet man nicht mehr an jeder Ecke oder in jeder Kneipe. Es ist halt schon so, dass sich das nicht durchgesetzt.
Ja klar, aber heute gibt es ganzen Nerds noch mehr davon als damals, die irgendwo einen Server oder einen virtuellen Server im Rechenzentrum haben und da auch irgendwie nicht nur Webseiten abvergangen können.
Völlig richtig. Was war früher die Motivation Fidunet Server zu betreiben? Das war, man war einfach an dem wilden Westen. Man hatte einen fast schon rechtsfreien Raum geschaffen, der noch unreguliert war. Man war irgendwo, wo es noch, wo noch niemand jemals zuvor gewesen ist, zumindest in dieser Form und dieser wilde Westen ist eben weitergewandert. Heute ist es vielleicht das Dezentrale Soziale Netz und wenn man diese Motivation, dieses Gefühl, dass etwas Neues, etwas Besonderes schaffen, wieder vielleicht wiederbelebt, dann könnte es auch dazu führen, dass sich solche starken sozialen Gruppen bilden, die dieses wiederum weitertragen und dann kann es passieren, dass du auf dem nächsten Konzert dann auch sagst, hey, wann kann ich dich wiedersehen? Hast du einen Facebook-Account und sagst, nein, ich habe einen Diaspora-Account.
Ich bin, also das hört sich sehr schöner, aber ich bin jetzt sagen, in der hin skeptisch, weil diese Fido-Sachen, hast du ja gerade gesagt, dass du sagen kannst, die geschlossene Gesellschaft, das ist das coole Underdog geschlossene Zirkelmäßige. Und genau, das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren, mit dem sozialen Netzwerk, wie wir es heute kennen.
Im Gegenteil. Die Frage ist, es darf halt nicht abgeschlossen sein. Es gibt ja heute schon so Netze parallel zu Facebook, die durchaus das Geschlossene als Vorteil sehen. A Small World zum Beispiel. A Small World ist ein geschlossenes Netzwerk, zu dem kannst du dich nicht anmelden. Zu dem musst du eingeladen werden. Und du musst also nicht einfach nur von irgendjemandem eingeladen werden, der schon da ist, sondern von jemandem, der wirklich auch approved in weiter ist. Und in dem Moment, wo du dich nicht ordentlich verhältst, wirst du auch wieder rausgeschmissen. Also es ist sozusagen ein absolutes Underdog in dem Fall. Hat sich auf eine ganz spezielle Zielgruppe fokussiert, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es eine Subkultur, die sich dort rausbildet und die sich deswegen weiter trägt, weil die Leute dort tatsächlich mit Mitglied sein wollen und eben mitdiskutieren wollen, mit kommunizieren wollen.
Im Grunde war diese Exklusivität einer der Unique Select Points von Facebook am Anfang. Dass die in Harvard gestartet sind, das war deren Trick, um die kritische Masse zu erreichen. Ich glaube, man kann da unheimlich viele neue Ideen entwickeln. Ich hab ihn jetzt auch nicht für diese Dinger. Insoweit gebe ich dir dann recht. Vielleicht wird er nicht passieren. Aber ich glaube, es eröffnet auf der Ebene drunter so viele andere Möglichkeiten. Sicher bin, da wird sich irgendwas entwickeln. Und da kann man endlos rumspinnen, um die Frage mit deiner Oma nochmals zu beantworten. Ach nee, das war deine Mutter. Man kann ja auch überlegen, das Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerk hängt im Bilderrahmen an der Wand. Ich stehe überhaupt nicht auf diesen blöden digitalen Bilderrahmen. Aber meine Mama steht da drauf. Und vielleicht ist das für die ein totales Usability-Feature, wenn sie sagen kann, okay, das, was ich da an der Wand sehe an Bildern, das ist das, was auch gleichzeitig auf meiner Wall nach außen auch gezeigt wird, an Bildern von in einem bestimmten Kreis, von der Hochzeit. Meines Sohnes oder ich weiß nicht was. Und wenn sie sagt so, ich hab keinen Bock mehr drauf, dann nehm ich das ab. Das kann ich auch alles sozusagen simulieren. Aber dass sozusagen, dass es wirklich stimmt, das ist schon ein Feature.
Also ich überlege gerade tatsächlich, ob das möglicherweise der Punkt sein könnte, wo ich dann zuschlagen würde, wenn man die Elternsehwanderer an der Wand sagt, ne Junge, wie geht's dir denn? Und dann sind sie auf Facebook, deine Frau, und du denkst, das will ich hier aber jetzt nicht so richtig erzählen. Und wenn du dann, tatsächlich könnte es möglicherweise ein Punkt sein, wenn man sagt, ok, pass mal auf, melde dich mal bitte da an. Wenn das dann sozusagen genauso leicht wie Facebook zu benutzen ist, dann macht das für die ja keinen Unterschied. Also für manche Leute, die die nutzen ja Facebook, sagen nur für eine ganz, ganz, ganz kleine, enge Gruppe von Leuten, dann sag ich so, pass auf, melde dich mal da an. Da kriegst du nämlich öfter mal ein Foto zu sehen, wie ich nachmittags ein Eis esse. Oder mit welcher Frau. Und das wäre dann möglicherweise tatsächlich ein Punkt, um so kleinere Gruppen dahin zu kriegen. Dann wäre noch die Frage, ob das dann skaliert hin zu, wie sind da alle unterwegs? Find ich spannend.
Also ich glaub auch, dass es ein schleichender Prozess sein wird und nicht den großen Knall geben wird, außer durch irgendwelche lustigen Zufälle, die die Geschichte vielleicht spielen wird. Sondern einfach wirklich dieses auf Empfehlung arbeitende. Ich mein, jeder braucht immer irgendwie mal einen Experten zum Thema Computer, der irgendwie einem da was einrichtet. Und da hört man auf eine Empfehlung. Und wenn die Nerds übereingekommen sind über eine Lösung, die sie sagen, das ist jetzt besser und jetzt haben auch Nerds Lust auf Social Networking, weil sie es halt irgendwie technisch irgendwie okay finden.
Der große Nerdrad ist zusammengegriffen und hat entschieden.
Genau. Dann wird sich das auch weiter rumsprechen und rumkommen. Und gerade in dem Land, in dem wir uns hier befinden, ist der Datenschutzer auch immer wieder so wichtig, dass man sich da nicht die großen Sorgen machen braucht.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt ein Nerd-Zertifikat für Diaspora.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal weitermachen.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall in einem Land, wo Zertifikate sehr wichtig sind. Aber auf jeden Fall, ich wollte nochmal die Verbindung, bevor wir hier zu Ende gesprochen haben, die Verbindung zu Second Life ziehen. Weil Second Life ist ja auch eigentlich sehr grandios gescheitert. Eigentlich kann man ja inzwischen schon so sagen, dass er jetzt auch...
Wird noch benutzt, höre ich total gerne zu Schulungszwecken. Also in einem kleinen Rahmen.
Sehr kleinen Rahmen.
Möglicherweise, ja.
Also ich weiß noch, vor drei oder vier Jahren hat Daimler damals also einen riesengroßen Betrag investiert, um die neue C-Klasse by Second Life auch so zu lancieren. Und das haben irgendwie andere Unternehmen auch getan. Die haben also ganz viel Geld in die Hand genommen, weil sie gesagt haben, das sind die wirklichen Meinungsträger. Das sind die Leute, die wir erreichen wollen. Und im Endeffekt bräuchte es ja auch bei Diaspora, wenn wir sagen, wir haben ein dezentrales Netzwerk, wir haben ein Netz, wo Leute tatsächlich auch vertrauensvoll miteinander kommunizieren. Trotzdem die Möglichkeit, Informationen zu lancieren. Vielleicht ist es ja nicht immer böse. Es muss ja auch nicht immer böse sein. Es kann ja auch tatsächlich eine wichtige Warnung vor dem EHC-Virus sein, die man eigentlich wirklich bekommen möchte.
Wie du meinst, es müsste so eine Art Schalter geben, der Nachrichten durchschlagen lässt aufs ganze Netzwerk?
Es müsste auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit geben, innerhalb von Gruppen oder Zwischengruppen, zwischen zusammengeschalteten subkulturellen Diaspora-Nodes, institutionalisiert zu kommunizieren. Das ist eben ein Unterschied, ob ich das jetzt einfach schreibe, ich gehe heute ins Kino, oder ob ich den aktuellen Kinoprogramm von meinem Lieblingskino haben möchte. Wenn das Kino das sozusagen anbietet, dann habe ich eine höhere Motivation, in diesem Netzwerk auch teilzunehmen. Also wenn es Radio sagt, benutzt alle Diaspora.
Wir hatten ja gerade noch einen Anrufer, der ein bisschen zu spät gefragt hat, warum Fritz Facebook benutzt. Das wäre nochmal eine interessante Diskussion gewesen, aber kurz vor 12 mit so einer Frage an das Ruf ist echt ein bisschen ungeschickt. Ich kann nur ganz kurz sagen, wir sind da, weil ihr da seid. Wenn ihr da nicht werdet, werden wir da auch nicht. Das ist sozusagen die ganz kurze Begründung. Aber das war ja nicht die Hauptsache jetzt hier. Von euch nochmal jetzt jeder einen Satz. Wann werden wir Diaspora benutzen?
Ich wollte noch kurz einen kleinen Ausblick nämlich machen, dass auch Punkte sind, die bewältigt werden müssen. Ganz schnell. Nämlich erstens brauchen wir alle ordentliches Internet zu Hause und da wird es am 8. Juni den IPv6 Testtag geben, wo alle neue IP-Adressen mal ausprobiert bekommen sollen. Erst wenn wir die haben, kann jeder wirklich zuverlässig zu Hause einen Server beschreiben. Und dann müssen natürlich noch die ganzen Techniker übereinkommen und den Schlachtplan machen, wie dieses Protokoll funktionieren soll. Und die werden sich auch nächste Woche treffen auf einer Konferenz, die der Jan organisiert. Vielleicht da noch mal kurz den Satz von dir.
Aber ganz kurz, sehr kurz. Das ist ganz schwer kurz zu beantworten, aber das ist das Ding, wovon ich vorhin erzählt habe. Zusammen mit dem W3C gibt es ein großes Treffen in Berlin.
Sag doch einfach, wie es heißt und wo die URL ist.
descent.org dcent.org Super.
Dann vielen Dank euch, für's hier gewesen sein, uns Dezentrale Netzwerke-isieren. Wollt ihr noch irgendeinen Account von euch verraten, wo man euch befreunden kann? Na, na, wer traut sich?
DerWetterfrosch auf Twitter.
ULD62datenschutzzentrum.de Mein Name kann sich eh keiner merken.
Alles klar. Dann bleibt mir nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.